So, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob wir jetzt Quality Options haben.
Haben wir jetzt Quality Options?
Tja Leute, dann stremen wohl zu viele Leute und ich krieg sie gerade auf Twitch nicht.
Da kann ich leider jetzt nichts machen, außer ich werde Twitch-Partner endlich mal irgendwann.
Dann krieg ich auch immer Quality Options.
Aber solange ich kein Twitch-Partner bin, bin ich halt quasi extrem so dritter Klasse,
was Quality Options angeht.
Oh, ich pause nochmal kurz auf Twitch.
Ey Leute, ich sage euch, ich hab quasi gestern den ganzen Tag rum probiert, hier den Gift-Player
zum Laufen zu kriegen, also nicht den da, sondern den High-Speed, DirectX, FFmpeg, sonst
als Gift-Player.
Und was unglaublich schwierig war, also das Gegenteil von, warum geht Easy nicht, ah,
das Fenster noch kleines.
Also das Gegenteil von Easy, das ist ey Windows, es ist so undurchsichtiger Kack ey teilweise.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man dafür überhaupt irgendwas ernstzunehmendes entwickeln kann
manchmal.
So, auf Twitch gepostet, äh, auf Twitter.
Ich bin schon komplett, wie er im Kopf, äh, so machen wir mal hier unsere Chill-Steps,
Chill-Steps-Sohle-Geschichte an.
Mal gucken, wie lautstärk ist.
Joa, joa, hoff mal den an, ach, das ist der, hoff an, der andere Icon, ey, ich mein Thumbnail.
Leute, das Windows-Teuch hat mich so kaputt gemacht im Kopf, ey, ich kann überhaupt keine
Wörter mehr aussprechen.
Ich bin wirklich komplett, komplett hinüber, was das angeht.
Also, ich hab hier das, das, das ekligste überhaupt produziert, ne, also man kann das,
man kann das nicht mal mal lesen, was ich hier gebastelt hab letztendlich, das müssen
wir jetzt aufräumen.
Ich hab hier quasi 365 Zeilen, irgendeinen Schritt zusammen gebastelt, dass es schnell
ist.
Auf den ersten Akt, ich zeige euch jetzt gleich mal, was da alles dahinter steckt, ey, es
ist der Wahnsinn.
Und es macht aktuell nicht mehr, außer ne noch nicht animierten Papagei anzeigen.
Mit 6000, na gut, das ist weil OBS im Hintergrund jetzt auch noch ein bisschen CPU braucht.
Mit 6500 FPS, ne nicht animierten Papagei, aber, man, man merke, der Papagei ist transparent.
Was meint ihr, was es für ein Akt war, diesen Scheiß transparent zu kriegen, das könnt
ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen.
Das ist wirklich, also was die sich bei Microsoft dabei gedacht haben, es ist mir vollkommen
schleierhaft.
Und es ist mir teilweise echt ein Rätsel, wie man, warum man dafür entwickelt.
Ey, das ist, also ich zeig euch das jetzt mal.
So, wir gehen da chat.
Wart mal, ich glaub meinen.
Ich muss mal kurz meinen Vorschau refreshen.
Letzte, was ich sehe, ist der Kühne in der Heimachs geschrieben hat, ich glaube nicht,
dass das das letzte war, dass er schon wieder irgendwie 6 Minuten her.
So, sagt mal was.
Ich weiß, dass mein Vorschaufenster geht.
So, ah ja, genau, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht der Chat wieder, der Boy next door, ja genau.
Jetzt haben, haben Gatschi besten.
Okay, also ich zeig euch das mal, ey, das, das, das haltet ihr im Kopf nicht aus, also
das ist so ungefähr, also wir räumen das jetzt auf, das ist wirklich ganz abartig,
ne.
Also das hier ist so ungefähr, was wir das letzte Mal auch hatten, bloß, dass es nicht
skaliert war, aber das hab ich jetzt auch mittlerweile eingebaut, dass es, dass es hier
schön skaliert und dass es nicht transparent war.
Und ich sag euch Leute, Transparenz unter Windows, ey, sowas undurchsichtiges ist der
Wahnsinn.
Erstmal, wenn man danach sucht, findet man nichts Gescheites.
Was man findet ist, sind in irgendwelchen Cheaterstellungsforen, ist kein Witz, ja,
also wenn man hier irgendwie danach sucht, wenn man jetzt hier zum Beispiel sucht, keine
Ahnung, Direct2D transparent overlay, wenn man irgendwie solche Dinge sucht, das erste,
was man findet sind irgendwelche Cheatforen, ja, weil das natürlich auch für viele Cheats
unerlässlich ist und das Schlimme ist, dass Microsoft dazu nichts Gescheites geschrieben
hat, es gibt 20 Millionen Optionen, die du setzen kannst, hier beim Erstellen vom Fenster
zum Beispiel, wo du nicht genau weißt, was der ganze Kram überhaupt macht.
Es ist, es ist, es ist komplett hier, achso ja, das Ziel heute, das Ziel heute kann ich
dir zeigen, also das Ziel generell ist, einen schnellen Giftplayer zu machen für mein Meme
Tool, weil ich zeig dir das mal, also wenn man hier jetzt zum Beispiel draufklickt,
hör mal, hör mal, klicken, zack, das braucht 2, 3 Sekunden oder vielleicht, na, so 1, 2
Sekunden hier, bis das geladen ist und angezeigt wird, aber kleinere Gifts gehen schneller,
aber man merkt, man merkt die Verzögerung, bei kleinen Gifts geht, hier hängt es schon
wieder, weil ich den jetzt erstmal wieder groß machen muss, so, aber hier hängt es
schon wieder, klick, so, und was wir machen, äh, Moment, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, ja
genau, was wir machen, wir basteln einen eigenen Giftplayer, den ich anstatt hier meinem WPF
Fenster verwenden kann.
Alles in Ram laden macht er ja, wenn du hier nämlich im Hintergrund guckst, das Ding braucht,
sobald du einen Gift aufmachst, 830 MB, weil er jeglichen Frame irgendwie in voller Auflösung,
in voller Farbe, mit allem in Ram lädt, für jedes Bild, und so ein Gift ist dann unglaublich
groß, vor allem in diesem komischen WPF Plugin, was ich verwende, und diese komischen WPF
Library, die ich verwende, fürs Anzeigen von Gifts, und das ist Müll, und erstens will
ich schneller haben, ja, und das darf auch gerne ein bisschen weniger Ram verbrauchen,
deswegen haben wir das letzte Mal angefangen, was eigenes zu basteln, mit FFmpeg und Direct2D,
man sieht schon, das braucht jetzt 85 MB, wir haben so ein bisschen, so ein paar kleinere
Memory Leaks haben wir hier, ja, ein paar kleinere Memory Leaks haben wir, aber sagen
wir mal so, das braucht halt 80 MB, und es ist gut, ja, und es geht halt mega schnell,
guck, sobald man sie zack, Gift ist da, und der muss jetzt die ganze Anwendung noch starten,
also das geht schon schneller, und die große Herausforderung, die es jetzt gab, das letzte
Mal haben wir das eigentlich ganz gut hingekriegt, das Gift zu animieren, das Gift zu animieren
ist auch kein Akt, das könnte ich jetzt auch wieder einfügen, da muss ich einfach hier,
wie gesagt, wir müssen das alles aufräumen, das ist Überbleibsel von meinem Rumprobierer,
ja, so, und hier lesen wir das Gift, irgendwo lesen wir das Gift, wo lesen wir das Gift?
Back it, Moment, wo lesen wir das Gift, da lesen wir das Gift, hier lesen wir das Gift
ein, also sprich, eigentlich um jetzt das Gift zu animieren, müsste ich jetzt bloß
noch den Kram, ich kann es ja mal kurz zeigen, dass wir jetzt einen Stand haben, wo das Gift
auch animiert läuft, machen wir mal hier unten hin, irgendwie so, zack, und jetzt machen
wir einen Sleep von, keine Ahnung, machen wir 100 Millisekunden, dass es nicht zu schnell
läuft, so, jetzt sollte das Gift, oder auch nicht, was auch immer, zumindest ist es kein
großartiges Akt, das Gift zu animieren, ähm, ich weiß gar nicht warum, was hat er jetzt
für Schmerzen, eh, egal, es ist total wirr, was ich hier gebaut habe, und das Schwierige
war wirklich, die Transparenz hinzukriegen, also das jetzt zu animieren, das kriegen wir
heute auch hin, also das Ziel ist heute, dass wir einen ordentlichen Giftplayer haben, nicht
hier mein hingerotztes Zeug, der schnell funktioniert und animierte Gifts abspielt, wie gesagt,
das Animieren ist nicht das Problem, das haben wir das letzte Mal schon gemacht, da kann
man sich einfach den nächsten Frame aus FFmpeg ziehen und gut ist, das haben wir ja auch
schon hin gebastelt, was wirklich schwierig war, und jetzt kommen wir mal wieder zurück
zu dem, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, es ist wirklich schwierig, ein transparentes
Windows zu machen, unter Windows, ein transparentes Windows, auf dem man malen kann, und ich
habe nur einen offiziellen Weg von Microsoft gefunden, alle anderen waren aus irgendwelchen
Cheatforen, die irgendwelche Dinge abusen, die man nicht machen sollte, zum Beispiel,
was ich ganz witzig fand, was ich rausgekriegt habe ist, ihr kennt doch dieses Nvidia Overlay,
was ich jetzt aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht einblenden darf, warum darf ich das denn nicht
einblenden, all diese GeForce Experience, das Ding ist so kaputt, so, Moment, ich mach
es mal an, Overlay, Overlay, zack, ja, besser hier, will kein Account, so, seht ihr das,
seht ihr das Nvidia Overlay, wie benutzt ihr FFmpeg mit C-Sharp, mit einem automatisch
generierten Binding, was es auf GitHub gibt, such mal nach, ich zeige es dir gleich, seht
ihr das Nvidia Overlay, oder seht ihr das im Stream nicht, muss man auf meinem Vorschau
Bildschirm gucken, ja, also man sieht das, man sieht das Nvidia Overlay, und da hab ich
rausgefunden, ich zeig dir mal kurz die FFmpeg Bindings, die du brauchst, das hier brauchst
du für FFmpeg von C-Sharp aus, den hier, FFmpeg autogen von Ruslan B, und dann musst du
quasi im Prinzip C-Style FFmpeg machen halt, plus aus die Sharp raus, so, und ich hab rausgekriegt
in diesen Cheat-Forum, die ich geguckt habe, was da teilweise für komische Hacks am Werke
sind, um nicht erkannt zu werden, das ist teilweise ganz witzig, und zwar sie verwenden dieses
Nvidia Overlay, was quasi kein Cheat, keine Cheat-Engine der Welt flaggen wird, weil es
ja das Nvidia Overlay ist, und das ist ja was Legitimes, die hijacken das so ein bisschen,
ja, also die crampen sich quasi das Nvidia Overlay und malen dann dort in das Nvidia
Overlay ihr eigenes Zeug rein, das ist eigentlich eine richtig geile Idee, ich mein, so Dinger
kann man alles machen, aber wir wollen ja gar nicht wie ein Cheat aussehen, weil wir
sind ja kein Cheat, und, das heißt alles, was ich hier so gefunden habe in diesen komischen
Hacks, hier also, die meisten, ohne Scheiß, die meisten Treffer zu wie man transparente
Overlays macht, sind in diesem Cheat-Forum, nach irgendwie 500 Stück oder so, ja, das ist
gar nicht wahr, danach kommt Stack-Overflow, aber es ist alles nicht sonderlich intuitiv,
das heißt, ich denke mal, und der Sebaro, der nimmt ja die Videos auch wieder auf, das
ist wahrscheinlich eine der wenigen Anleitungen, was wir heute im Stream machen, wenn nicht
die einzige weltweit, die quasi nicht auf irgendeinem Cheat-Scheiß basiert, auf offiziellen
Lösungen von Microsoft basiert und ein funktionierendes Beispiel hier im Stream hat, transparente
Fenster, ja, und ja, gibt es Punktabzug, wenn der Player als Cheat erkannt wird, dann geht
die Anzeige raus an den Anti-Cheat-Entwickler, also mehr als den offiziellen Microsoft-Weg
befolgen, können wir nicht tun, können wir wirklich nicht machen, und der offizielle
Microsoft-Weg ist, also, dass man hier so ein transparentes Fenster kriegt, der Witz
ist ja, das Fenster muss nicht nur von der Farbe transparent sein, sondern man muss auch
durchklicken können, das Ding wird safe detected, ey, ohne Scheiß, ich kann halt nichts dagegen
machen, ähm, was soll ich tun jetzt endlich, ja, wenn die Funktionen, die in Windows eingebaut
sind, vollkommen legitim sind, sogar Microsoft in Anleitungen verwendet, von irgendwelchen
Anti-Cheat-Tools erkannt werden, weiß ich auch nicht, ja, aber gut, was willst du machen,
ich meine, die Cheat-Entwickler können den ganzen gleich, können den gleichen Kram verwenden,
und ich hoffe ja mal, dass das Anti-Cheat-Zeug nicht wild flaggt, sondern quasi schon mal
gucken, zu welchen Programmen gehört das und sonst was, weil, ich meine, das Video-Overlay
wird ja auch nicht geflaggt, lol, alter, so, und, ja, der einzige Weg, den ich gefunden
habe, wie man das offiziell macht, ist ein Artikel von Microsoft, den muss ich jetzt
mal finden, das war irgendwie, ähm, wofür machst du das, zum GIFs anzeigen als Overlay,
zum Beispiel, guck mal, ähm, hier kann ich GIFs als Overlay anzeigen lassen, das funktioniert
auch gut, das ist auf, das ist auf WPF-Basis, das klappt ganz gut, das Problem ist nur,
dass, ähm, diese Library für WPF ziemlich lahm ist, bei großen GIFs wie dem hier zum
Beispiel, guck mal, klickste, und jetzt ist es erst da, so, deswegen wollte ich selbst
einen Overlay basteln, was, ähm, GIFs anzeigen kann, und das geht auch schon, guck mal da,
zack, GIF da, und rendert so ungefähr mit 7000 FPS, wenn man es mal, wenn man es sich
ein bisschen ein, einlaufen lässt, ja, so irgendwas, pfff, wenn man es sich ein bisschen einlaufen
lässt, ja, wenn man es ein bisschen ein, wenn es ein bisschen gelaufen ist, dann hast du
eben 7000 FPS, aber, ähm, es ist schon, es ist schon deutlich schneller, aber auch viel,
viel weniger RAM, das andere brauch ich wie 800 MB RAM für so ein publisches GIF, und
das hier ist mit komplettem Fenster und allem irgendwie bei 80.
Dann soll sie mich halt als suspicious flaggen, wenn das Leute, wenn das, wenn das, äh, ganz
viele verwenden, also viele, ich weiß nicht, was für die viele ist, 30, 40 Leute, ja,
und irgendwann, wenn sie mal nachgucken, um was es da eigentlich geht, ansonsten sind
sie auch, ansonsten sind die Anti-Cheat Hersteller auch nicht besser als irgendwelche Virenprogrammierer,
wenn sie einfach blind da irgendwelche Sachen machen, vor allem, wenn sie halt viele Leute
haben, und dann muss man halt auch mal einfach gucken, was dahinter steckt, ich mein, der
ist ausgeholt, er ist offen auf GitHub, kann sich hier da angucken, so, und der einzige
Weg, und jetzt, jetzt pass auf, jetzt Leute, jetzt wird's übelst abenteuerlich, den einzigen
Weg, den ich gefunden habe, bei Microsoft, wie man das macht, ist, ha, ich, wie hießen
diese Artikel, ähm, da war irgendwas von 2014, ich muss euch den mal zeigen, weil der Artikel
selbst ist schon wieder übelst abgedreht, ey, ähm, kann man das irgendwie nicht, das
kann man doch auf Seiten einstellen, Side, so, und ich hab, das ist ein Artikel, der ist
von C++, ich hab den so ein bisschen, quasi, für, äh, sharpdx übersetzt, dass der damit
funktioniert, ha, ok, allerdings in dieser komischen Artikel, ah, da kommen da Sachen
doch schon näher, kann man nicht noch irgendwie nach Datum 2014 oder suchen, ok, dann suchen
wir mal nach Microsoft, das da, das ist es glaube ich, ja, das ist es, das ist der einzige
Artikel von Microsoft, den ich zu dem Thema gefunden habe, aber auch nicht auf Deutsch,
ich hab das schon auf, wo stellt man hier die Sprache um, Sprache, Sprache, ich will
das nicht auf Deutsch, wo stellt man hier, ah, da unten, English and all that, ok, so,
das ist der einzige Artikel, den ich gefunden hab, und das ist schon, und das ist wohlgemerkt
von 2014, und so macht es auch keine Cheat, kein Cheat, den ich bisher irgendwie da in
diesem anderen Forum gesehen hab, macht es nach dem offiziellen Microsoft Weg, die machen
alle so krumme Dinge, also irgendwie, NVIDIA Overlay hijacken, irgendwelche, irgendwelche
Window, ähm, Window Manager Geschichten abgreifen und so, aber das ist der einzige
Weg von Microsoft, den ich gefunden habe, transparentes Window auszumachen, wo man schnell
reinzeichnen kann.
Ja, stimmt, Lesezeit ist keine schlechte Idee, so, und jetzt nur so zu erklären, der Typ
labert halt hier ein bisschen rum, so, und der Artikel ist halt in C, C++, was ist das,
ich würde sagen, das ist eher C, da ist noch nicht mal was mit C++, ähm, also, die Beispiele,
die sie da haben, sind in C, und ich hab das versucht, so ungefähr nachzubauen, was der
Duta treibt, ja, und, ey, es ist wir, es ist, es ist mega wir, also die Essenz aus dem ganzen,
ich zeig's euch mal, gleich bei mir im Code, ähm, stimmt, das sind Lambdas, das müssen
C++ sein, ähm, so, und da zeigt der hier, blablabla, Window erstellen, blablabla, transparentes
Window erstellen, ja, also, Bricht, das ist, Microsoft sagt selbst, so funktioniert's,
also, ja, gut, kann sich nicht davor schützen, dass es irgendeinen Anti-Cheat-Typ fleckt,
so, hier, guck, transparentes Window, blablabla, DirectX, blablabla, blablabla, ganz viel
Blah, den ganzen Scheiß hab ich ausprobiert und in C Sharp, äh, Sharp DX zu übersetzen,
ja, also, so, blablabla, dann steht hier zwischendrin irgendwas von der Direct Composition API, wenn
du nach Direct Composition suchst, findest du ein Video von Microsoft im Jahr 2013, also,
das ist wirklich der Abgrund, der Abgrund, wirklich, der komplette Abgrund, den ich, in
den du hier schaust, Bob, von Windows, wieder, ähm, so, und am Ende zeigt der dir dann halt,
wie geil er ist, er hat ein Fenster am Start mit einem grünen Kreis drauf, und letztendlich
ist es ja das, was wir auch wollen, das Einzige, was wir danach noch machen müssen, ist, den
Fensterrahmen weg, war es aber kein Ding, wichtig ist erstmal, dass man ein transparentes Fenster
bekommt und dass man reinmalen kann, so, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal, wie das geht, weil
wir wollen uns ja nicht diesen komischen Artikel von dem Typ angucken, sondern wie ich das gemacht
hab, und Leute, es ist Magic pur, es ist wirklich Magic pur, ähm, ich kann, wie gesagt, ich
kann euch gar nicht erklären, ich kann euch erklären, was ich gemacht hab, aber nicht
warum das an manchen Stellen so aussieht, ähm, fangen wir erstmal oben an, ne, wir fangen,
wir fangen beim interessanten Teil an, also das erste, was ich mach, wir räumen das jetzt
gleich auf, das ist auch Ziel dieses Streams, ne ordentliche Giftplayer-Klasse zu machen
und meine ganzen, ganzen Scheiße hier rauszuschmeißen, das Ding hat jetzt irgendwie 400 Zeilen
gekocht, danach hat es wahrscheinlich noch 150, wenn wir fertig sind, ja, und das hier,
diese Funktion ist das auch, was die ganzen Cheat-Tools immer verwenden, ich hab auch
als probiert, das damit hinzukriegen, funktioniert, aber, und jetzt kommt der Hit, es ist langsamer
als meine Lösung, Layered-Window mit, ähm, diesem, dieser Geschichte ist langsamer als
das, was ich gebastelt hab, also ist die offizielle Microsoft-Lösung wahrscheinlich gar nicht
mal so schlecht, aber wahrscheinlich nicht so flexibel, was, äh, natürlich wieder für,
äh, Cheat-Geschichten schlecht ist, ja, also hier kannst du halt auch wirklich nur dein
eigenes Fenster malen, alles andere kannst du vergessen, was halt bei den Cheat-Dingern
nicht so ist, ne, aber wir wollen ja auch nicht cheaten, das ist wie gesagt die einzige
offizielle Microsoft-Lösung, so, ähm, also wo gehts denn los, also als erstes müssen
wir irgendwie DirectX-Gedöns erstellen, äh, das ist für mich zum größten Teil Magic,
was diese Optionen hier machen, allerdings braucht man diese Option, sonst funktioniert
es nicht, und, ganz wichtig, auch, auch wirklich sehr praktischer Tipp, wenn ihr mal DirectX-Zeug
macht, wusste ich bis vor kurzem auch nicht, das Ding schmeißt laufend, wenn es sich an
irgendwas stört, Fehler, und die Fehler sind halt überhaupt nicht aussagekräftig, da steht
dann einfach nur ein DirectX-Error oder sowas, da, da kann man, ähm, da kann man, oh alter,
wo war das denn jetzt versteckt, ich glaub hier irgendwo, da kann man hier in den Projekt-Settings
unter Debug, kann man einstellen Enable Native Code Debugging, wenn man das eingestellt hat
und an sein DirectX-Device hier die Option Debug dran steckt, dann, da wirds zwar ein
bisschen langsamer bis man Debug wieder rausnimmt, aber dann wirft DirectX sinnvolle, und überraschend
sinnvolle hab ich mich selbst gewundert, Fehlermeldungen, allerdings nicht auf die Konsole, sondern
hier in dieses Output-Window, also wenn ihr mal irgendwas mit DirectX oder irgendwelche
Windows-AP-Geschäfts macht, macht Native Code Debugging an und schaltet die Debuggeschichten
hier für euer DirectX-Device ein, dann bekommt ihr zum größten Teil recht sinnvolle Fehlermeldungen,
und so hab ich mich auch hier so ein bisschen ran getastet, zum Beispiel, ich hatte keine
Ahnung, dass ich Flip-Discard verwenden muss für meine Swap-Chain anstatt Discard, weil
ich weiß es nicht, weil nur das das supportete ist für dieses Szenario, weil man, ich weiß
es nicht, aber Microsoft sagt das in der Fehlermeldung, so, ähm, ähm, achso, den Link, den Link kann
ich dir geben, ja, du willst bestimmt jetzt deinen Cheat updaten, gibs zu, so, wo lernt
man die Grundlagen von C, Youtube-Videos oder irgendwelche Bücher oder sonst was, wobei
ich sagen würde, ich würde, also wenn du schon was programmieren kannst und was Low-Level-mäßiges
machen willst, ist nicht verkehrt, mit, äh, sich das mal anzugucken, allerdings muss man
sagen, einsteigen würde ich mit C auf keinen Fall, äh, Sebaru, ich hab probiert Quality-Settings
zu kriegen, gar nicht funktioniert, so, ok, also, fangen wir mal an, die Magic kommt später,
erst mal zur Erklärung, was am Anfang passiert, das ist relativ standard, DiamondX gedürzt,
man erst, man erstellt eine Swap-Chain, eine Swap-Chain, das ist, DiamondX hat, also ich
muss ja sagen, ich persönlich finde die OpenGL Sachen ein bisschen angenehmer benannt,
vor allem wenn man sowas wie SDL oder irgendwie, äh, OpenTK oder sowas verwendet, das ist
irgendwie ein bisschen griffiger, finde ich, als vieles DiamondX Zeug, wobei, das eigentlich
nimmt sich nichts, dafür ist OpenGL viel, ähm, nerviger, weil man viel mehr selbst
machen muss, ähm, naja, zumindest, als erstes muss man eine Swap-Chain-Description erstellen,
damit man eine Swap-Chain erstellen kann, ähm, eine Swap-Chain ist im Prinzip eine,
im Prinzip mehrere Buffer, die du, die du, die du austauschen kannst, das ist eigentlich
alles was eine Swap-Chain ist, im Großen und Ganzen, du hast, du hast einen Buffer, da
wird gerade, also das was da drinne ist wird angezeigt, und du hast in der Regel noch einen
zweiten Buffer, da schreibst du dein Zeug rein, und wenn du fertig bist, dein, dein
neues Bild reinzuschreiben, dann swapst du das Ganze, also sprich, den Buffer, den du
gerade anzeigst, den schmeißt du weg, und zeigst deinen Buffer an, den du gerade reingeschrieben
hast und swapst halt, ne, deswegen musst du auch hier einstellen, das Swap-Effekt, und
in dem Fall muss, muss man, warum auch immer, weil Microsoft, muss man Flip-Discard verwenden,
natürlich auch kein Hilfedext, warum, es gibt noch zig andere Varianten, das ist der
Effekt, wenn man diese beiden Buffers switcht, also sprich, von dem Buffer, wo das angezeigte
Bild ist, wenn ich dann switche zu dem Buffer, wo ich gerade reingerendert hab, ne, dann,
aber in dem Fall muss ich Flip-Discard oder Flip-Sequential nehmen, weil das Microsoft
gerne hätte, unterstützt wird aktuell generell wohl, so wie es aussieht, fast nur noch, Alpha-Mode
pre-multiplied, da hab ich, ey, ohne Scheiß, da hab ich Stunden gebraucht für, bis ich
gecheckt hab, aber das zeig ich euch gleich noch, zeig ich euch gleich noch, wie ich
mein Gift transparent bekomme, also es gibt prinzipiell zwei verschiedene, Alpha-Modi,
die DirectX, Direct2D und DirectX unterstützt, das ist einmal pre-multiplied und straight,
der Unterschied ist im Prinzip relativ subtil auf den ersten Blick, weil die Anzahl der
Bites sind die gleichen, also ein Pixel, ja, ein Pixel ist, besteht zum Beispiel, also
man, ein, ein, genau, rot, ein roter Pixel, ja, ein roter Pixel sind erstmal drei Bites,
erstmal drei Bites, und zwar die Bites 2, 5, 5, 0, 0, also hier, ne, erstes Bite 255,
zweites Bite 0, drittes Bite 0, so, das ist erstmal ein roter Pixel, jetzt gibt's da
zusätzlich noch ein viertes Bite, der sagt, ähm, wie transparent dieser Pixel ist, deswegen
ist das normale, ist das sowas wie RGB, das hatte jeder schonmal gehört, und, ähm, RGB,
das ist da quasi zwei, zwei Dinger, bringt's, falls ich irgendwelche Host Donations oder
sonst was vergesse, spammt mich mal voll, weil ich hab wieder vergessen meine Alert-Dinger
anzumachen, so, und, wenn man jetzt, das sind Alpha, äh, also, Alpha-Channel-Information,
sprich, wie transparent der Pixel ist, 0 ist transparent, 255 ist komplett nicht transparent,
also wenn ich sowas mache wie 100, dann ist das so halbtransparent, das muss natürlich
das jeweilige Backend unterstützen, aber das ist eigentlich Standard heute, deswegen nennt
sich das nicht mehr RGB, sondern RGBA, also sprich, rot, grün, blau, Transparenz, so,
und intern, um die ganze Sache noch ein bisschen komplizierter zu machen, intern arbeitet DirectX
bzw. Direct3D, äh, Direct2D, in dem Fall nicht mit RGBA, sondern mit BGRA, weil, wahrscheinlich
weil's besser für das Speicherlayout von Grafikkarten ist oder so, ich weiß es nicht
genau, ähm, zumindest intern verwenden sie das da, aber das macht im Prinzip keinen
großen Unterschied, das ist im Prinzip einfach nur ein paar Sachen vertauscht, Alpha-Byte
ist immer das letzte, so, und jetzt wollte ich ja erklären, was der Unterschied ist zwischen
Pre-Multiplied und das braucht ihr immer, wenn ihr irgendwelche Grafikgeschichten macht,
müsst ihr euch das merken, ähm, wie ist die Lage, sehr verwirrend ist die Lage, Windows
Zeugs wieder am Start, also der Unterschied ist, den Hilfetext hier könnt ihr erstmal
vergessen, also Pre-Multiplied, also fangen wir mal an, Straight, ja, jetzt, jetzt, äh,
keine Feminism-Chokes oder sowas, also Straight bedeutet in dem Fall, die Pixel hier vorne
stellen ganz klassisch Rot, Grün, Blau da, und nur der letzte, steht für die Transparenz
von dem kompletten Pixel, so, Pre-Multiplied bedeutet, die Transparenz ist quasi hier
vorne schon mit eingerechnet, ganz ehrlich, Vor- und Nachteile habe ich nicht so wirklich
gecheckt, also ich weiß, im Hinterkopf ist mir schon lange klar, dass es das gibt, aber
ich hatte damit noch nie Probleme, ähm, deswegen musste ich mir das heute erstmal angucken,
was eigentlich auch der Unterschied ist, zumindest Pre-Multiplied bedeutet genau das, was da
steht, nämlich, dass der Alpha-Wert schon eingerechnet ist in das normale RGB, das bedeutet
Pre-Multiplied, so, und nachdem, und ich muss jetzt ein bisschen ausholen, sonst versteht
man nämlich das eigentliche Problem bei der ganzen Sache gar nicht, nachdem jetzt quasi
meine komplette Geschichte, die ich hier initialisiere am Anfang, zwingend dieses Format braucht
für Pixel, also sprich, blau, grün, rot und Alpha-Channel und sein Alpha-Channel Pre-Multiplied
haben will, also das geht einfach davon aus, das macht da keine Magic mehr oder so, also
sprich, wenn der Pixel Pre-Multiplied nicht transparent ist, dann wird er einfach nicht
transparent angezeigt, da kann mein Alpha-Channel noch so sehr auf Null stehen, das juckt ihn
dann überhaupt nicht, ist dem vollkommen egal, und das heißt, ich kann meine normalen Bilder,
sprich die einzelnen Frames vom GIF, nicht so einfach rendern, weil die sind nicht durchsichtig,
und ihr seht ja, wenn man es hier anzeigt, hier sind sie durchsichtig, normalerweise
hatte das immer weiß gerendert hier im Hintergrund, weil es nicht Pre-Multiplied war, so, aber
noch mal ein Schritt zurück, wir müssen ja irgendwie diesen Inhalt, bevor wir Probleme
überhaupt mit Transparenz oder sonstigen Dingern haben, wir müssen ja erstmal den ganzen Kram
überhaupt in unser transparentes Fenster rein kriegen, und jetzt beginnt die Magic,
also wir erstellen hier mal unsere Swap-Chain-Description, habe ich ja gerade erklärt, was die einzelnen
Optionen machen, der Rest ist nicht so wichtig, Höhe, Breite noch, wie das Fenster halt ist,
dann erstelle ich das DirectX-Device, muss ich sagen, ich nehme ja auch nochmal BGH-Support,
das braucht man für Direct2D, wir wollen plus das neueste DirectX haben, weil wir halt krasse
Checker sind und nur das neueste verwenden, geht wahrscheinlich mit älteren Sachen ganz
genauso gut, so, dann speichern wir uns das hier in unserer Klasse, das DirectX-Device,
dann kommt, jetzt kommt Magic, jetzt kommt übelste Magic, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum
man das genau machen muss, jetzt braucht man irgendwie so ein DXGI-Device, danach muss man
sich eine Factory erstellen von diesem DXGI-Device, danach kann ich mal eine Swap-Chain erstellen,
das ist das, was ich vorhin erklärt habe, wo du deine Buffer switchen kannst mit, der
braucht die Factory, die braucht das DXGI-Device und die Description, dass ihr weiß, was ihr
für Settings haben soll, so, und jetzt, ich habe schon die Warnung hier reingeschrieben,
jetzt kommt komplette Magic, weil, aktuell ist es so, ich habe ein Fenster erstellt, das
ist transparent und hat keinen Hintergrund, das habe ich genauso gemacht, wie der Dude
hier im Artikel, ich habe ein Fenster erstellt, was keinen Hintergrund hat, also kein, nein,
was keine, was kein Bitmap quasi reserviert hat im Speicher von Windows, wo man überhaupt
Content reinmalen könnte, also sprich, mit Windows-Bordmittel kann man in dieses Fenster
nicht zeichnen, weil es keinen Buffer hat, gibt's nicht, ja, also, irgendwelche GDI-Dinger
oder so von früher, das geht da nicht, das geht schreckt, nice, ähm, warum entwickelst
du eigentlich nicht auf Linux, weil das, ähm, ziemlich Windows-Only hier ist, was ich gerade
mache, deswegen mache ich es nicht unter Linux, weil das ist halt, gibt's halt unter
Linux nicht, naja, zumindest, wo bin ich denn jetzt stehen geblieben, genau, absolute Magic,
wie gesagt, das Fenster, das, auf das kann man nicht malen, auf dieses Fenster, mit,
das ist genau das gleiche, wie der Typ hier im Artikel macht, plus, dass ich bei mir
auch den Rahmen ausgeblendet hab, ähm, so, ja, mit Qt kannst du's machen, aber ich bringe
mir in dem Fall auch nix, weil, ähm, das andere ist auch Windows-Only, das ist voll
komisch, ja, ähm, und also mit Qt ist gar nicht so einfach, Qt ist ja erstmal standardmäßig,
äh, also, du machst mit QML, ist es ja auch nicht großartig beschleunigt, das heißt,
da müsste es mit OpenGL irgendwas passen, kein Nerv, wir sind eh relativ abhängig
von Windows und dementsprechend, machen wir das jetzt mit DiamondX, dann ist es halt noch
mehr Windows, na, also im Prinzip ist das das gleiche Fenster, wie der Typ im Artikel,
ähm, so, und plus, dass ich den Rahmen ausgeblendet hab, ok, und jetzt kommt absolute Magic,
ähm, nachdem wir ja, wie ich grad erklärt hab, hier nix reinmalen können auf klassische
Art und Weise in dieses Fenster, müssen wir dem, was, wie heißt das eigentlich, korrekt,
DWM, Desktop Window Manager wahrscheinlich, Dynamik Window Manager, ne, das ist das Linux-Ding,
Windows, für was steht denn das hier überhaupt, der Desktop Window Manager, also sprich, das
ist der Part von Windows, der dafür zuständig ist, ähm, so Sachen wie überlappende Fenster
zu machen, halbtransparente, was ist denn ein halbtransparentes Fenster, gibt's sowas
unter Windows 10, noch standardmäßig, kann man auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall machen,
ja, also sprich, dass dieses Fenster über diesem Fenster ist, oder das, was haben wir
denn hier, halbtransparentes, gibt's hier nichts, noch was halbtransparentes zum zeigen,
zumindest ich, ich starte einfach jetzt mal mein Programm, ja, dass hier dieses Fenster
da drüber ist, und dieses Fenster dafür, dafür ist dieser, dieser Desktop Window Manager
zuständig, das heißt, nachdem unser Fenster jetzt kein Buffer hat, in dem wir malen können,
müssen wir das Ganze quasi mit dem Desktop Window Manager in das Fenster malen, das ist
das, was der Typ hier in seiner Anleitung beschreibt, wie das Ganze funktioniert, ach stimmt, der,
der Calculator ist transparent, ja, richtig, oder auch, der, ich, ich gebe dir aber recht,
der sollte eigentlich transparent sein, ich bilde mir auch an, dass der transparent ist,
ich, ach, nee, weißt du was, warum das nicht transparent ist, weil ich Transparenz abgeschaltet
hab, lull, ich hab Transparenz abgeschaltet, weil mir Transparenz auf den Keks gegangen
ist, stimmt, ähm, der ist minimal transparent, ich glaube nicht, dass der transparent ist,
hier ist nichts transparent, ich hab das abgeschaltet, aber guckt mal, hier unten die Taskleiste
ist ein bisschen transparent, seht ihr's, da, ne, das macht alles der Desktop Window
Manager, so, und mit dem müssen wir jetzt, mit, mit, mit Direct Composition, müssen wir
in unser Fenster malen, wohlgemerkt, das hier ist immer noch ein transparentes Fenster,
so, und ich hab keine Ahnung, was diese nächsten paar Dinger machen, aber sie funktionieren,
die hab ich mir mehr oder weniger eins zu eins hier aus diesem C++ geschwuppelt, äh,
ja, doch aus diesem C++ geschwuppelt, aus dem Artikel übersetzt nach Sharp DX, so, und
was da jetzt passiert, ist folgendes, ähm, als erstes muss ich ein Direct Composition
Device erstellen, aus meinem DXGI Device, warum, weiß nur Microsoft, ich hab keine
Ahnung, muss man aber machen, als nächstes, und, ey, das ist, das ist die übelste Magic,
also wirklich, ich weiß nicht, was da passiert, als nächstes muss ich, ähm, ein Target erstellen,
ein, ein Direct Composition Target erstellen, ähm, was denn jetzt mit dem, irgendwie hör
ich mich anders an, oder, äh, ich glaub, wartet mal, hatt ich grad einen Wackelkontakt
oder so, ja, jetzt geht's wieder, vielleicht ist mein, vielleicht ist mein Gehirn auch
einfach nur kaputt langsam, zumindest muss ich jetzt ein Direct Composition Target erstellen,
von meinem Fenster, also von dem transparenten Fenster, den ihr nicht, das ist das, was man
hier an der Stelle nicht sieht, ähm, ja, davon muss ich ein, ein, ein Direct Composition
Target erstellen, mit Handle von meinem Windows Form, und dem muss ich das Direct Composition
Device übergeben, danach muss ich, es wird, es wird immer abgedreht, ohne Scheiß, ich
weiß, ich weiß wirklich nicht, was hier passiert, aber es funktioniert, danach muss
ich ein Direct Composition Visual erstellen, wo ich dann das Composition Device reinstecke,
weil das es wohl irgendwie braucht, und danach muss ich sagen, dieses Visual kriegt den Content
von meiner Swap Chain, dann muss ich sagen, das Root Element ist dann das neue Visual,
und dann muss ich das Ganze committen auf meinem Composition Device, und dann wird alles
über den Desktop Window Manager, was ich hier in meiner normalen Direct X Swap Chain rendere,
in meinen Fenster, beim Compositionen reingerendert, so, alter, ja, was auch immer, es ist komplett,
hier, also es ist absolut für den Arsch, ja, dass das überhaupt so ein Riesenakt ist,
aber zumindest ist es der einzige Artikel von Microsoft, den ich gefunden habe, der sich
mit diesem Thema beschäftigt, und die sagen, so geht's, und es geht tatsächlich, und es
ist schnell, es ist wirklich schnell, es ist schneller als dieses ganze Zeug, was man da
zum Beispiel in irgendwelchen Cheat Foren findet, die auch Overlays machen wollen,
das ist so um den Faktor 20% ungefähr schneller, also es ist schneller als Layered Windows
mit Client-Area-Gedöns, also es ist wirklich schnell, das sieht man ja auch, Windows ist
oft schwarze Magie, es ist wirklich komplett schwarze Magie, aber es funktioniert an der
Stelle, und ich bin wirklich vordach, dass das Ganze funktioniert, weil es ist schnell,
es ist transparent, und es funktioniert, man sieht hier, guck, ich kann hier durchklicken,
eigentlich ist hier das Fenster, es ist Fenster drum herum, ich kann hier durchklicken, ohne
Probleme hier, das einzige was verdeckt sind die Visual Studio Menüs, warum auch immer,
aber damit kann ich leben, immerhin gibt es einen Artikel von Microsoft, das ist richtig,
immerhin, immerhin, so, ja, und als nächstes zeige ich euch, was man machen muss, um das
Bild transparent zu kriegen, weil wer gedacht hätte, damit ist die größte Hürde genommen,
der hat sich wirklich getäuscht, aber vorher Leute, muss ich mal kurz aufs Klo, ich brauche
mal einen Text hier, auf Klo, so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder
da.
So, ich bin wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so,
ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder da,
so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder da,
so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder
da, so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder da, so, ich bin gleich wieder
Gut, jetzt habe ich euch erklärt, wie man es schafft, quasi sein diode x Zeug in seinen
Vendor zu rendern, das ist ja quasi das, was hier beschrieben ist, dazu gibt es immerhin
noch einen Artikel, zu dem anderen, was ich euch jetzt zeige, wie ich das Bild überhaupt
transparent gekriegt habe, gibt es keinen Artikel, aber ich vermute mal jeder, der sowas
öfters macht, dem wird es wahrscheinlich halbwegs klar sein, wo das Problem gewesen
ist. In der Pause, das 3DS, anvoxen mit dem Friseur, oh, das war noch Zeit, nein, das
war noch, das ist schon ewig her, das war 2011 oder so. Poggers. Ok, weiter gehts. So,
und jetzt kommt der nächste Knackpunkt, das Bild, was wir von unserem animierten GIF
auslesen, also aktuell ist es nur das erste Bild, aber trifft für alle weiteren Bild
natürlich auch zu, das hat einen Alpha Channel, also sprich, das hat eine Anzeige, das hat
transparente Farbe, hier, außen drum, sieht man ja, weil das Bild ist transparent, aber
das Ding wurde die ganze Zeit nicht transparent gerendert. Bis ich dann auf die glorreiche
Idee gekommen bin, mir mal zu überlegen, warum das Ganze nicht funktioniert. Erstmal
habe ich wild gesucht, Google und sonst was, so wie malt man ordentlich Bilder in Direct2D,
aber ergibt zwar Anleitungen, aber so wirklich eine Beschreibung, wie ich transparente Bilder
male, gibt es irgendwie nicht. Und das liegt einfach daran, dass Bilder, die den korrekten
Alpha Channel haben, einfach standardmäßig transparent sind. Problem ist bloß, und deswegen,
sonst nochmal zurückzukommen auf diese Geschichte hier, Problem ist nur, dass natürlich mein
GIF, also der frame, der erste frame von diesem GIF, also das erste Bild von der GIF-Animation,
das ist zwar im richtigen Farbformat, das sieht man ja auch, weil die Farben sind richtig,
also sprich, das ist zwar im Format BGRA, allerdings, es ist Alpha Mode quasi straight
und nicht pre-multiplied und deswegen hat ich die ganze Zeit hier, wo ich, ich hab mich
kaputt gesucht, war der Hintergrund weiß und nicht transparent. Bis ich dann auf die
glorreiche Idee gekommen bin, ich muss das Ganze einfach multiplied und dann gehts. Und
wie man das macht, zeige ich euch jetzt mal schnell. Und danach fangen wir an, neue Sachen
zu basteln bzw. das hier aufzuräumen und unser FFmpeg Zeug thread-sicher in eine eigene
Klasse zu verpacken. So, also jetzt zeige ich euch, wie man das Ganze macht. Hier ist
ganz viel Geschiss drin, was man eigentlich gar nicht mehr braucht. Ich hab übrigens
meinen komischen FPS-Counter, hab ich weggeschmissen, wir machen das FPS hier in der Render-Loop
drinne. Das ist im Prinzip noch das gleiche hässliche Kram vom letzten Mal, nix Neues
dazu gekommen. FFmpeg, bla, GIF einlesen, weiteres Rennen hab ich übersprungen, wir
lesen bloß den ersten, wir lesen bloß das erste Bild ein. Dann hab ich hier noch irgendwas,
das brauchen wir gar nicht mehr, oder? Lol. Also, wie gesagt, der Code ist jetzt nicht
wie 400 Zeilen lang, der ist danach wahrscheinlich noch 150 oder so. Den Scheiß können wir
auch rausmachen, da wollte ich gucken, ob das auch im richtigen Farbformat ist. Prender,
gibt es da noch? Der Prender, da bitt man Prender Tage, brauchen wir auch alles gar
nicht mehr eigentlich. Ist eigentlich komplett overrated, den können wir schonmal löschen,
der Prender. Der Name ist so geil, der ist mir nix eingefallen, der Prender, der Prender-Renderer.
Ok, und jetzt kommt der Knackpunkt, wie kriegt man das Bild? Von straight zu pre-multiplied,
und da gibt es was schönes, also entweder macht man das von Hand, das ist auch kein
Ding, da muss man halt jeden Pixel mal dem Alpha-Value nehmen durch 255, dann hat man
das ganze pre-multiplied. Aber, da gibt es schon was fertiges in DirectX, und zwar gibt
es Effects. Und ein Effekt ist pre-multiply. Und pre-multiply funktioniert relativ einfach,
kriegt man alles Effekt an, und als Input sagt man einfach hier dieses Bitmap. Und dann
macht er das für ein, da wandelt er quasi den straight Alpha-Channel in pre-multiplied
über alle Beis von jeweils den Pixel um. Und danach habe ich noch was gemacht, danach
skaliere ich das Bild noch hoch auf die jeweilige Fensterbreite, mit dem richtigen Seitenverhältnis.
Das ist gar nicht so kompliziert, das ist, hier kriege ich raus, Scale 1, Scale 2, warum
heißt das so? Weil man weiß das nicht genau. Die Dinger können wir dann auch mal ordentlich
nennen. Das ist der Effekt für die Transparenz, und das hier ist der Scale-Effekt. So, und
ich gehe mal davon aus, dass er das halt ziemlich effizient in Hardware auf der Grafikkarte
macht. Unten habe ich noch mal Scales. Die brauche ich aber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
So. Und hier passiert jetzt das, was ich euch eben erklärt habe mit dem Bild. Der schreibt
das Alpha, den Alpha-Channel um von straight zu pre-multiplied und skaliert das Ganze auf
die, also in der passenden Seitenverhältnis auf das Fenster hoch. Das hat auch ewig gedauert,
bis ich das raus gekriegt habe letztendlich. Das steht in keinem Guide und in sonst nichts
drinne. Irgendwo. Kannste knicken. Aber es ist im Prinzip ganz logisch, wenn man sich
das überlegt. Ich habe nämlich die ganze Zeit versucht, sowas hier zu machen. Ich wollte
ihm nämlich sagen, alter mein Bitmap ist nicht pre-multiplied. Und wenn man das probiert,
dann crash das Ganze, wie man hier sieht. Er macht nichts im Endeffekt. Weil eben in
meiner Swap-Chain gar kein straight erlaubt ist. Und ich habe wirklich ewig rum probiert,
bis ich dann mal so den Geistesblitz irgendwo hatte, ey wandel doch einfach mal dein straight
in pre-multiplied um. Und seitdem funktioniert das Ganze und wird auch noch schön skaliert
und ist dementsprechend, weil es wahrscheinlich auf der GPU läuft, auch relativ zackig. So.
Und dann kommt im Prinzip das, was wir das letzte Mal auch gemacht haben. Das ist übrigens
ganz wichtig, wenn man transparente Fenster malen will. Dann muss man hier sagen, man
cleart den Background mit Null. Wenn man das nämlich nicht macht, wenn man zum Beispiel
irgendwie sagt, keine Ahnung, color so blue oder so, dann ist der Hintergrund halt blau
oder halt hellblau oder keine Ahnung. Indian Red oder sowas. Das will man ja nicht. Das
heißt, man muss hier sagen, clear Null. Und dann ist es nämlich, dann ist das quasi
halt durchsichtig, der Hintergrund. So. Und da ist ganz viel geschwummelt drin, was ich
nicht brauche. Und das hier ist der eigentliche Kniff, wie man dann den ganzen Krempel rendert,
wie man hier oben zusammengebastelt hat. Wir haben ja hier das Bild mit dem RGB-Werten
vom GIF drinne. Dann haben wir hier die Effekte, die quasi das Premultiply und danach skalieren.
Und hier kann man dann quasi sagen, mal das Bild, als Output nimmst du das Bild von den
Effekten und dann kann man es auch ein bisschen verschieben. Das müssen wir übrigens gleich
machen, weil das Bild ist, werden wir gleich sehen, wenn wir das Bild animieren, das Bild
ist dann zwischenzeitlich ein bisschen abgeschnitten. Das ist da, das ist ein bisschen, nicht so
praktisch. Das ist dann hier oben abgeschnitten und links und rechts ein bisschen abgeschnitten.
Deswegen müssen wir hier sagen, dass wir das Ganze ein bisschen tiefer, tiefer setzen.
Aber das machen wir dann, wenn es soweit ist. Guck, ich zeig's euch mal mit den FPS zum
Beispiel. Wenn ich die direkt oben in der linken Ecke male, dann ist ein bisschen was
abgeschnitten. Warum, bin ich mir noch nicht so ganz sicher. So. Und das war's im Prinzip
schon. Und da hab ich gestern quasi fast den ganzen Tag noch dran rum probiert, bis ich
das auf die Reihe gekriegt hab. Es ist wirklich, es sieht jetzt relativ simpel aus, aber es
war wirklich übelst kompliziert. So, und jetzt werden wir den ganzen Scheiß ein bisschen
aufräumen und einen ordentlichen GIF-Decoder-Buzzle mit FFM-Pack, der nicht hier quasi alles
versorgt. Wir löschen erstmal alle möglichen Dinge, die wir nicht mehr brauchen, weil ich
mein, offensichtlich, es läuft ja gerade. Es läuft ja gerade, also sprich, warum, also
brauchen wir ja anscheinend von dem ganzen Kram nichts, der hier drinne steht. Ganzes
Kommentar soll ich rauslöschen. So, meinen Magic-Hinweis kann ich auch löschen. Debug-Mode
hab ich weg. Der ganze Mist hier oben kann auch weg. Das kann auch weg. Das brauchen
wir aber auch alles nicht mehr. Das hier brauchen wir noch, sonst gehts nämlich nicht. So, siehste,
allein durch das löschen sind wir jetzt schon mal 100 Zeilen Code weniger. Jetzt werden
wir noch dieses ganze FFM-Pack Zeug auslagern und ich überleg grad, wo wir da am besten
mit anfangen. Also erstmal sollten wir gucken, ob das hier unten schon halbwegs sinnig ist.
Wir zählen am Anfang unsere FPS, ok. Wir skalieren. Copy-for-memory für das Bitmap,
das müssen wir dann später in der Schleife machen. Also sprich, das müssen wir später
müssen wir das hier machen, weil wir updaten ja pro Durchgang unser Bild. Ey, jetzt ist
es nicht mal skaliert. Hab ich irgendwas zu viel gelöscht? Monkeys. Ach nee, ich mach
das andere auch noch außerhalb von der Schleife. Ja, das ist kein Wunder, dass das jetzt noch
nicht... Moment, was hab ich jetzt gemacht? Was hab ich jetzt gemacht? Ich hab doch gar
nichts geändert. Warum ist das Bild jetzt kleiner? Ah, ich weiß warum. Weil ich die
Größe gelöscht hab, was natürlich Blödsinn ist. Die sollte ich mal lieber da lassen.
So. Jetzt wird er ordentlich gross. Ja gut, manchmal muss man sich auch nicht wundern,
oder? Höhe, Breite. Alles gut. So, und ich würd sagen, wir fangen jetzt mal damit an,
das ganze FFMPEG Zeug auszulagern in eine eigene Klasse. So, den Max-FPS-Counter können
wir löschen, den brauchen wir nicht mehr. Wir counten das jetzt in der Schleife drin.
Es ist relativ einfach, ja. Wir gucken, wann wir angefangen haben von der Zeit her. Dann
gucken wir, was für eine Zeit jetzt ist, und dann gucken wir quasi, wenn jetzt größer
ist als Startzeit plus eine Sekunde. Dann ist halt eine Sekunde rum. Dann gucken wir,
wieviel FPS wir gezählt haben, schreiben sie in FPS und setzen die Frameset auf Null.
Also, eigentlich recht einfach. Ja, TheraFox sagt hier nicht, dass es hier nicht nur Optimierungspotenzial
gibt. Genau, so. Jetzt weiter im Text. Also, wir machen jetzt eine Klasse für den FFMPEG,
für den GIF-Decoder, dass es hier ein bisschen aufgeräumt ist. So, das Ding nennen wir auch
ganz billig. GIF-Decoder. Das ist noch übrig. What the fuck? Wir schreiben das jetzt einfach.
GIF-Decoder. Do you want to check the file and replace it? Yes. Schreckt. Okay, also,
wir machen jetzt einen GIF-Decoder, und was das Ding auf jeden Fall braucht, ist den Dateiname
von der Datei, die wir wiedergeben wollen. Ich meine, wie soll das Ding was decoden können
aus der Datei, wenn es nicht weiß, ob es decoden soll? Also, irgendwie logisch, wenn er nicht
weiß, wo das GIF ist, kann er ja auch schlecht. Das seht ihr ja auch hier. Also, ich muss
ja irgendwo das GIF angeben, wo es liegt. So, also, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall für
unseren GIF-Decoder, brauchen wir den Pfad, wo das GIF liegt, und wir machen mal so eine
Variable, die nennen wir irgendwie Loop, und die ist standardmäßig, keine Ahnung, was
standardmäßig ist, also sprich, der soll das GIF in Endlosschleife basteln. Und wir
werden es jetzt ganz am Anfang, wir werden am Anfang keines Leaps oder sonst was einbauen.
Wir gucken einfach mal, wie schnell man das GIF, wie gesagt, mein Hirn ist schon komplett
matsch heute, wie schnell man das GIF quasi rendern kann, wie oft wir das in der Sekunde
hinkriegen in Endlosschleife, also in Animationsschleife, von Anfang bis Ende, von Ende bis Anfang,
von Anfang bis Ende, also wie oft wir einfach das GIF loopen können pro Sekunde. Mal schauen.
Genau, so, jetzt gruppieren wir uns mal den ganzen Krempel, den wir hier quasi in unserer
Renderfunktion trennten, gruppieren wir uns jetzt erstmal in unseren GIF-Decoder, weil
es sollte später so sein, dass die ganze Winno-Klasse, diese ganze Formklasse überhaupt nichts mehr
von FFmpeg weiß und wissen muss. Das ist eigentlich Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Alles
mit FFmpeg machen wir hier drin. Achso, unsave, das ganze muss unsave sein und das unsave
können wir dann hier wieder raus machen, wenn wir fertig sind, weil unsave, weil Pointer
und Gedöns, ne. So, dann brauchen wir jetzt den Initialisierungscode von hier, also Format-Context,
wir kopieren uns das jetzt einfach mal rüber. Es kommt in Constructor von unserem GIF-Decoder
rein, weil es ist ja im Prinzip ganz logisch, wenn das Ding angelegt wird, wenn irgendein
GIF-Decoder anlegt, dann lese ich die Datei ein und lege so die Sachen an, die ich brauche,
damit ich, wenn man play drückt oder wenn man abspielen will das GIF, dass schon alles
geladen ist. So, dann nehmen wir das hier, das müssen wir ein bisschen anpassen, weil
das ist jetzt kein hardcoded Fahrt mehr, sondern der Fahrt den ich übergebe. So viel Setup
für eine von außen einfache Sache. Richtig. Richtig. Es sieht super simpel aus, ne, ein
paar GIFs abzuspielen quasi als Overlay über allen anderen Fenstern. Wenn irgendeiner
sagt, ey, zeig mal ein GIF an quasi als Overlay, dann denkt man doch, ey, das ist kein Akt.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es auch ein paar Programme für, wie man das machen kann. Es gibt ja
viele Programme, die quasi Top-Moused-Windows setzen können und auch noch manche Fenster
transparent machen können und so. Aber das wirklich richtig zu machen, ordentlich und
schnell zu machen, es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so ohne. Würde man gar nicht denken.
So, wir kopieren uns unseren ganzen FFM-Pack-Code rüber, den wir schon das letzte Mal gebastelt
haben, von dem wir wissen, dass er funktioniert. Hier lesen wir ein Dateiformat, also sprich,
was es ist, wie viele Frames es hat, also wie viele FPS es hat, wie lang es ist und so
was. Dann brauchen wir den Krempel hier noch. Mal gucken, bis wann wir alles in Constructor
packen. Oder wann in die Play-Methode. Oder wie nennen wir sie? Decode nennen wir sie.
Play. Play wäre für den Decoder ziemlich blöd. Find-Decoder, Decoder, Blah, Package. So,
mehr brauchen wir erstmal nicht. Jetzt ist der Kram hier alles initialisiert. Packages
und Stream werfe ich weg. Das machen wir später. Legen wir das neu an, weil das brauchen wir
bloß in der Methode, wo wir dann auch unser GIF-Decode, die brauchen wir nicht global.
So, und jetzt können wir eigentlich schon anfangen, das Ganze zu rendern. Stream. Äh,
ups, hab ich den aus Versehen gelöscht. Hab ich aus Versehen gelöscht. Wollte ich
gar nicht. Ich wollte Package löschen, Package und Frame löschen und nicht Stream. So, ok.
Können wir das hier irgendwie ein bisschen schöner schreiben? So. So. So, ha, das sieht
ganz gut aus. Ok, ich versuche immer so, die Sachen immer so, dass die logisch zusammengehören,
so einen Block stehen zu lassen, eine Leerzeit dazwischen zu machen. Das ist ein bisschen
persönliche Ansicht, wie es einem am besten gefällt. So, und jetzt braucht man als nächstes,
also wir machen uns jetzt eine, ich zeige euch jetzt mal, wie man das Ganze thread-sicher
macht. Ich hab dann nämlich schon so eine Idee, wie wir das machen. Das heißt, an der
Stelle legen wir jetzt einen neuen GIF-Decoder an und übergeben dem mal einen hardcoded-Fart
wieder. Und zwar, was nehmen wir denn mal? Komm, wir nehmen, wir nehmen, wir nehmen wieder
den Papagei, der Papagei ist schon ok. Mit dem, mit dem Dateipfad im Constructor musst
du für jede Datei einen eigenen Instanz erstellen. Ja, das will ich aber auch so. So, Decoder,
so jetzt brauchen wir sowas wie, wir brauchen einen Task, damit wir das Ganze quasi in einem
eigenen Thread laufen lassen können, das decoden. Müssen wir ja letztendlich, wir wollen ja
unser, unser GUI Zeug nicht blocken, was nicht unbedingt sein muss. So, dann machen wir eine
Methode, ich kann nicht rein, irgendwie decode, ne, ne, ne, wir nennen das alles, wir nennen
das Start, aber wir machen, oh, ich hab eine Idee. Wir machen das jetzt richtig pro, wir
machen das jetzt richtig pro, pass mal auf. Jetzt, jetzt zeig ich euch mal was, jetzt
kommt hier wirklich high IQ Proggerskills an, Schatz. Also wir machen, wir machen eine Start-Methode,
vorher sagen wir uns im Constructor auch Task, irgendwie New Task und dann brauchen wir noch
eine Methode, die der Task ausführt und das wird die Methode decode, decode decode, werden
wir jetzt gleich nochmal einfügen lassen. So, wunderbar und in Start machen wir nix
anderes als das Task, äh, Start. Soweit, so gut, erstmal relativ einfach. So, und jetzt
waren wir in Trick 17, jetzt waren wir in Trick 17. Ähm, ich, wir müssen, wir müssen
danach nochmal gucken, ich hab nämlich im Hinterkopf, dass es irgendwie mit C-Sharp bzw. mit irgendwie
einem der letzten.NET Updates was gab, um das noch schöner zu machen. Vielleicht weiß
da ja einer was von euch und zwar, von der Idee her machen wir das jetzt so, wir haben
ja hier einmal unseren, nennen wir es mal GUI Thread, also sprich das Ding, wo Diode
X drinne läuft, haben wir hier unser Diode X Zeug und das hier, das Decode von dem GIF
läuft in einem separaten Thread ab. Und jetzt ist es ja so, ich muss ja irgendwie, dieses
Dis, ja ich mach das gerne. Es gibt Leute, die machen dann so Dinger hier wie, äh, Private,
blub, gleich eins, so, so Dinger, ja. Also, so Dinger machen viele gerne. Aber ich mag
ehrlich gesagt, äh, das lieber, wenn meine Klassen-Dinger quasi meine Instanzvariablen
halt nicht Unterstrich haben und ich jedes Mal ein This davor schreibe. Das ist komplett
Geschmackssache, kann jeder machen wie er will. Und, ähm, ein Task ist nicht zwangsläufig
ein neuer Thread, das stimmt, aber in der Regel ist das ein neuer Thread und zwar im
Standard Threadpool, den es halt so gibt. Und es sei denn, man macht den Task mit Long
Running, dann ist es ein eigenständiger Thread. Ansonsten ist ein Task in der Regel aber ein
anderer neuer Thread. Miint, ja, okay, man kann es natürlich immer noch weiter, weiter
versauen, ja. Es ist aber Geschmackssache. In welchem Fall ist denn ein neuer Task, in
welchem Fall ist denn ein Task kein neuer Thread? Mir fällt jetzt da gar nicht so viel
ein, ehrlich gesagt. Ich muss jetzt mal Backup mit ein paar Beispielen. Der sagt ja auch
sogar hier irgendwo, dass, ähm, das standardmäßig halt im Threadpool läuft, dass es Default
ist. Guck. Was, wenn der Main Thread nicht blockiert ist, dann ist es... Achso, ja. Ist
das so. Also ich dachte eigentlich, dass standardmäßig, wenn du einen Task anwirfst, dass das immer
in den Standard Threadpool geworfen wird. Steht doch sogar da. Use Specific Work to Run
on Threadpool and Return Task Object. Oder ist es ein Unterschied zwischen Task Run und
New Task? Zumindest läuft es parallel. Wir blockieren nichts, das ist ja das Wichtige
an der Stelle.
Das stimmt natürlich, der nimmt irgendwas, was frei ist. Es geht aber hauptsächlich
darum, quasi den Kram nicht zu blockieren und das erreichen wir auf jeden Fall. So,
ähm, genau. Decode, bla, bla, start. So, und jetzt in unserer Decode Methode werden wir
uns die einzelnen Bilder aus dem GIF rausholen. Jetzt war er Trick 17. Ich hatte nämlich
gerade eine gute Idee. Und das kann sein, dass es, wie gesagt, in C-Sharp 7 oder in
ein oder neuen.NET Versionen noch was Besseres gibt. Ich bild mir ein, dass ich irgendeinen
Vortrag von der letzten Bild oder der vorletzten Bild gesehen hab, wo sie genau was zu diesem
Thema erzählt haben. Ist das hier noch immer das Meme Board? Ja, es wird weiter verbessert.
Und zwar aktuell hast du das Problem, wenn du auf GIFs drückst, hast du ja gerade das
Klicken gehört, das dauert ewig. Wir basteln jetzt unser eigenes GIF Overlay, dass das
schneller geht. Und das, das, das wird auch deutlich schneller gehen. Geht ja jetzt schon
schneller. Viel, viel schneller. Braucht anstatt 58 MB nur 80 MB. Ähm, genau, wir machen
jetzt, pass mal auf, jetzt kommt's hier, jetzt, äh, wir nehmen jetzt eine Blocking Collection
und zwar von AV Frame. Wir nennen das Ganze Frames. So, Default Value. Das ist, das ist
auch ein schönes neues, ich glaube, Sie schreiben sieben Feature. Du kannst jetzt sagen, ey,
ähm, dieses Property hat nur einen Getter, also sprich, du kannst da nichts Neues reinschreiben.
Ähm, also keine, keine neue Collection zuweisen, aber du kannst einmal zum Initialisieren hier
was reinschreiben. Sonst müsstest du das halt hier im Constructor machen. So, ähm,
und Blocking Collection hat eine ganz schöne Eigenschaft. Erstens, das Ding ist Red Sicher.
Und das Zweite ist, es hält quasi, es blockiert die andere Seite, wenn nicht, wenn nicht genug
Bilder da sind. Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus, mal gucken, ob das das ist, was wir haben
wollen. Und ich denke aber mal, dass wir ziemlich schnell in der Lage sind, neue Giftbilder
zu decoden und dass wir auch ziemlich schnell in der Lage sind, Sachen zu rendern. Und eine
Sache müssen wir noch machen, man kann nämlich der Collection angeben, dass wir maximal
100 Items queuen wollen. Weil, sonst hätten wir den Fall, ähm, mal genommen, wir hätten
einen riesen GIF und unser GIF decoded viel, viel schneller als wir es rendern können,
würde das hier quasi voll laufen mit neuen, neuen Bildern. Deswegen sagen wir, ey, 100
Bilder im Voraus berechnen ist erstmal genug, es ist kaum ein GIF mit 100 Bildern finden,
äh, mehr als 100 Bilder im Voraus berechnen ist genug, im Zweifelsfall dann block halt
hier dein Decoding so lange, bis eins abgearbeitet ist. Und auf der anderen Seite sollte das hier
leer sein, dann blockt das Rendern, was wir auch in einem separaten Task laufen lassen,
blockt das Rendern vom DirectX. Sollte hier nichts drin sein. Und da müssen wir uns nicht
um irgendwelche Fälle kümmern mit, es ist nichts da, es ist null drinne, es kackt ab
oder sonst was in der Richtung. Es hängt dann einfach bis auf beiden Seiten irgendwie
was drinne ist. So, und das heißt in unserem Decode lesen wir jetzt die einzelnen Bilder
vom GIF aus und schreiben dann die Bilder in diese Collection rein. Soweit, soweit zu
gut. Ähm, also von der Idee her haben wir dann sowas hier wie, an der Stelle brauchen
wir hier Frame, so haben wir den Decoder, Decoder, Decoder, Frames, Take, so. Und an
der Stelle ist es jetzt so, wenn hier nichts drinne ist in Frames, weil unser GIF Decoder
angenommen zu lahm ist, dann würde es an der Stelle blockieren und nicht weiter rendern,
bis das, ähm, bis was drinne ist. Das heißt, ohne es ist thread-sicher, das ist natürlich
ultra praktisch, das heißt ich muss mich hier um nichts kümmern. Moin, du hast doch immer
noch deinen Server zuhause, wie hast du den gegen Angriffe von außen abgesichert mit
einer Firewall und TLS oder, ähm, es gibt keine Zugriffe von außen. Deswegen muss
ich da auch nichts absichern. Das einzige, was es gibt, ist, ähm, ein OpenVPN. Das ist
das einzige, was es gibt. Aber ansonsten, es gibt keine wirklichen Zugriffe von außen,
deswegen muss ich ja auch nichts großartig absichern. Und mein Nextcloud und das ganze
Zeug, das ist quasi nur intern verfügbar oder wenn man per VPN angemeldet ist. Also
sprich, das funktioniert dann auch nur von meinen Geräten aus, wo ich auch ein VPN
drauf installieren kann. Ansonsten, äh, fragst du, weil du selbst was absichern willst, also
ich kann dir erzählen, wie ich das machen würde, wenn ich es von außen erreichbar
würde. So, ähm, DecoderFramesTake, TakeFrame, das ist ein AV-Frame. So, und jetzt können
wir den ganzen Krampel hier löschen. Den brauchen wir drüben in unserer Decode-Methode
drin. Ähm, so, Frame, Frame, das muss den ganzen Krampel ersetzen. Die ganzen Pointers
ersetzen durch Punkte. Und wir dürfen nicht vergessen, den Frame wieder aufzuräumen.
Dann ist MemoryLeak des Todes angesagt. Okay, so weit so gut. Gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt
prinzipiell funktioniert. Also, wir decoden den ganzen Krampel, blablabla, Frame, Packet.
Also, müssen wir hier ein neues Packet pro Durchlauf anlegen. Sagen wir hier, Packet
gleich new AV-Packet. Und sagen Frame gleich new AV-Frame. So, blablabla, Add. Achso, ja,
genau, dann müssen wir Referenz übergeben. Und sagen Add Frame. So, und jetzt gucken
wir mal, ob es funktioniert. Es sollte eigentlich jetzt immer noch der Vogel rauskommen. Macht
er aber nicht. Okay, da habe ich einen, achso, ich muss das Ganze noch starten. Haha, haben
wir noch nicht gestartet. Decoder, Start. Kann ja nicht funktionieren. Bam! Es nimmt,
es nimmt Formen an, Leute. Es nimmt Formen an. Was wird denn das, wenn es fertig ist?
Das wird ein Gift-Player, der schneller ist als der normale WPF-Gift-Player. Guck hier,
klick, wie lang das braucht. Und meiner ist dann der High-Speed-Gift-Player mit 6000 FPS
die Sekunde. Wie im Titel steht, der schnellste Gift-Player der Welt wird das. Also, Woosa,
wäre cool, wenn du uns mal erzählen willst. Also, wenn ich von außen was verfügbar machen
würde, das Beste, was du machst, ist natürlich erstmal VPN, da gibt es relativ wenig Probleme.
Das nächste sind Client-Zertifikate, auch immer wunderbar. Allerdings möchtest du
das oftmals von außen zugänglich machen, ohne dass der andere eine Zeremonie abziehen
muss, dass er darauf zugreifen kann. Und da ist das einfachste, also erstmal brauchst
du ein paar Zertifikate. Wenn du das Ganze verschlüsselt machen willst, da empfiehlt
sich Let's Encrypt und ich würde nie meine Anwendung direkt Port weiterleiten oder direkt
freigeben in der Firewall. Ich würde das Ganze immer über, wenn es HTTP ist, aber das meiste
ist ja HTTP, würde ich das über den Reverse-Proxy laufen lassen, dann nehme ich meistens EngineX
für, aber es gibt auch zig andere Sachen, die du da verwenden kannst. Ich verwende
meistens EngineX für, EngineX und Let's Encrypt mit Zertport funktioniert auch wunderbar
zusammen, dann hast du quasi einen EngineX zwischen deinem Dienst und zwischen außen.
Das heißt, da kannst du auch wunderbar quasi hinter einer Domain auf mehreren Ports quasi
Dinger laufen lassen oder quasi mehrere Subdomains intern auf unterschiedliche Dinger mappen
oder sowas. Dann kannst du dir überlegen, ob du noch eine Authentifizierung machst über
EngineX. Du könntest beispielsweise, wenn du sagst, ok, ich will es möglichst einfach
haben, dann machst du halt einen EngineX als Reverse-Proxy dazwischen und holst dir Let's
Encrypt-Zertifikate und dann machst du halt, wenn du willst, dass es simpel ist und du
noch ein bisschen Authentifizierung hast, dann machst du dem EngineX einfach Basic Auth
und dann musst du halt Passwort und Username irgendwie mit deinen Leuten austauschen, aber
das ist das Einfachste, was du machen kannst und das ist dann aber schon relativ gut. Natürlich
gibt es dann noch unendlich viele weitere advancede Varianten, du kannst hier sogar
einen To-Fack der Authentifizierung basteln mit, gibt es auch so Keycloak oder irgendwie
sowas, wo dann der EngineX einen Request dagegen macht, so nach dem Autodata-Typ und
sowas. Aber die einfachste Variante dürfte wirklich sein, Let's Encrypt-EngineX oder
irgendeiner anderen Reverse-Proxy und Basic Auth davor und gut ist. Läuft schon, es läuft
mit einem Bild und ist transparent, Patrick. Also es ist schon deutlich besser als das
letzte Mal und du hast das ganze Intro verpasst, wie sehr es mich genervt hat, ein transparentes
Fenster und ein transparentes GIF selbst zu ändern. Riesenakt. Okay, Decoder-Start, zack,
da ist er. Und sogar schön gescaled. Okay, jetzt müssen wir natürlich nur einstellen,
dass mehr Frames abgerufen werden. Okay, kann ich noch ein bisschen was löschen von dem
ganzen Krämpel hier, den ich da hab? Bla, bla, bla. Bla, bla, bla, kann ich davor noch
irgendwas wegschmeißen? Nee, glaub ich nicht. Okay, Copy from Memory, Frame, Decoder-Start,
Decoder-Start. Gut, das hier muss ich in der Schleife machen. Das Bitmap kann ich ja vorher
schon anlegen, das ist kein Problem. Das muss ich in der Schleife machen und ich muss einmal
pro Schleifendurchgang einen neuen Frame holen, also am Ende vom Durchgang. So, jetzt sollte
eigentlich das GIF animiert sein und ist es auch, plus es ist viel zu schnell. Ich vermute
mal, dass das ist. Wollen wir mal ein Sleep irgendwie dazwischen, 100 Millisekunden, da
ist es. Bam, danach kackt es ab. Logischerweise kackt es danach ab, weil es gibt keinen Frame
mehr, richtig so. Aber, Animation in Form an. Warum genau kackt das ab, Frame? Na eigentlich
abkacken sollte es doch nicht. Der letzte Frame ist doch immer noch drin, oder? Jetzt
muss ich mal überlegen, warum kackt das an der Stelle ab. Also, wir müssen den Frame
eh auf jeden Fall wieder löschen, weil das haben wir in Memory Leak. Das wollen wir nicht.
Also im Prinzip funktioniert es, aber wenn die Animation fertig ist, kackt er ab, weil
wahrscheinlich hier der Kram nicht... wo kackt... was war? Paint kackt er ab? Das ist wahrscheinlich
ein Bug, dass er bei Paint abkackt. Also wahrscheinlich hat er hier irgendwie Probleme mit dem Speicherbereich,
wobei ist den Frame doch eigentlich... ach nee, ha, nee, Moment. Das sollte doch eigentlich
hängen, wenn nichts mal drinnen ist. Also warum der abkackt ist mir jetzt nicht so ganz
klar ehrlich gesagt.
Hm. Warum kackt er ab? Kannst du mal erklären, was das Endpoint der Fernandam-Struktur ist?
Das ist quasi die Managed-Variante von einem Pointer. Ja, alles gut. Sharks Development.
Warum kackt er denn ab an der Stelle? Ich meine, es ist nicht schlimm, wir laden ja
eh die Bilder dann nochmal neu, aber er sollte definitiv nicht abkacken, wenn keine Bilder...
also von der Idee her sollte es folgendermaßen sein. Ah, ich weiß woran das liegt. Das Ding
hier kackt ab. Wartet mal, ich hab ne Idee. Wir machen mal... die Coden mal wieder nur
ein Frame. Siehste, jetzt kackts nämlich nicht ab. Das kackt gar nicht ab, das ist Fail.
Das kackt in Wirklichkeit nämlich der Gift-Decoder ab, was ganz klar ist, weil er nicht weiter
lesen kann. Ich muss hier nämlich gucken. If Error F of Mpeg. Ok, das muss ich mir
jetzt mal abgucken von dem, was wir das letzte Mal gemacht haben. Das war an das EOF oder
sowas, ne? Ja, genau. Sprich, wenn das File fertig gelesen ist, dann darf er nicht weitermachen.
Da muss er machen Break. Ha, guckt, und jetzt kackt das Ganze auch nicht mehr ab. Das lag
nämlich gar nicht an unserem Render, das lag am Decoder, der abgekackt ist und die Exception
war nur an einer komplett Fail-Stelle. Memory Leaks werden wir gleich ordentlich produzieren,
ich hab's im Gefühl. So, und jetzt müssen wir eine Möglichkeit finden, wie wir das
Ganze resetten. Also der Witz ist jetzt ja, wir können, also wir haben jetzt ein relativ
langes Leap drin, dass wir sehen, dass die Animation funktioniert, wir machen das Leap
dann ein kleines Mal raus, wenn wir es geschafft haben, quasi eine endlos Gift-Schleife zu
decoden. Also von der Idee her würde ich mal sagen, was übrigens auch toll fällt,
wir haben 0 FPS. Wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, wie man mit FFmpeg quasi zurückspringt hier,
weil wir lesen ja immer noch, wir haben ja hier irgendwo einen neuen, wir haben ja hier
irgendwo einen Stream und wir lesen Frames, Frames, Frames, Frames, sondern irgendwann
sind wir am Ende, End of File und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie FFmpeg ja wieder sagen, geh
an den Anfang des Files zurück. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man das macht, da müssen wir
mal versuchen. FFmpeg Reset File. Ja, das kann man auch machen, wir könnten auch einfach
alle Frames zwischenspeichern, das geht auch. Aber ich will mal gucken, wie man resettet.
How to Reset AV Format Context so it could be reused. Das ist schonmal gut. Ok, da hat
keiner Antwort gekriegt. Wisst ihr was, wir sollen jetzt mal Stack Overflow dabei. FFmpeg
Reset Start Time of File. AV Frame. Position. Man muss einfach nur gut suchen können. FFmpeg
Position File Context. Reset. Seeking. Seek. Seek.
Text. Have you come?
Ihr seht jetzt gerade Stack Overflow Driven Programming in Aktion. Seeking with AV Seek
Frame. I.O. Stream. Set. Wir kommen da Sache langsam näher.
AV Seek Frame hatten wir das schon oder hast du gewusst? Ist doch. AV Seek Frame.
Seek. Set.
Das muss ja irgendwie funktionieren.
Also, wenn wir hier EOF haben, dann müssen wir sagen, was AV Seek, AV Seek Frame, Kontext,
was für einen Kontext brauchen wir denn an der Stelle, ahja, Format, ok, Format, Kontext,
Stream Index, Stream Index ist 0, GIF hat nur 1 Stream, Timestamp, wo wir hin wollen,
die Tote, Keyframe, Timestamp, 0, Inflax, 0, ob das jetzt funktioniert, ob das jetzt
funktioniert, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert.
Äh, Scheiße, das funktioniert, krass, übrigens, wir haben ein paar Memory Dex, aber, ich
glaube, es funktioniert, ich bin echt überrascht jetzt, ne, guck mal, wir leaken ein bisschen
Memory, so ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen Memory liegen wir, das liegt aber
daran, dass ich auch nichts frei gebe, ok, gucken wir mal, also, wir sagen, ok, das Packet
brauchen wir nicht, Package freen können wir, Frame freen können wir nicht, also, FFMPack,
Free Packet, Deprecated, drauf geschissen, jetzt leaken wir schon eine ganze Ecke weniger,
Free Packet ist obsolete, Use Packet Unwraff, machen wir, Dust Dust 1717, äh, kennst du
dich mit FFMPack aus, oder woher weißt du das alles, ok, wir liegen, wir liegen noch
ein bisschen an anderen Stellen, wie es aussieht, wahrscheinlich in unserem DirectX, DirectX
Krämpel, müssen wir mal gucken, ja, garantiert, garantiert, wir müssen hier noch aufräumen,
wir müssen mal gucken, an welcher Stelle, so, und jetzt müssen wir hier am Ende, müssen
wir noch sagen, FFMPack, wahrscheinlich auch Unwraff, Unwraff Frame, sondern jetzt sollten
wir weniger leaken, achso, auch bin ich blöd, vielleicht sollten wir das davor machen, bevor
wir uns den neuen holen, guck mal, wir liegen nicht mehr, weil das, äh, wir machen das
mit Open, mit DirectX, weil es Windows Only ist, also, so, und jetzt nehmen wir mal das
Lieb raus, mal gucken, was passiert, alter, ich sag doch, der schnellste Giftplayer der
Welt, wisst ihr, dazu passt jetzt richtig gut,
ich bin begeistert
Nice, gut, mal in den normalen Modus wieder wechseln,
warum ist die Musik gar nicht so leise, ich mein, guck mal, wir schaffen es jetzt,
meine Platte ist wahrscheinlich auch voll am, oh ja, mein SSD ist ein bisschen am blinken,
ich mein, guck mal, wir haben ja die Frames noch nicht mal gecached oder so, wir lesen
das quasi immer neu ein, erstellen immer neue AP-Acte und wir rendern das quasi mit
maximal 1200 FPS oder so, das ist doch schonmal sehr ordentlich, allerdings soll das Ganze
natürlich nicht ganz so hektisch sein, aber nice, das funktioniert schonmal, und wir brauchen
auch nur 90, 90, 90 MB RAM, warum steht denn so überhaupt auf Release, soll ich auf Release
stehen, wow, es ist kaputt, warum geht das kaputt,
warum geht das kaputt, wenn es auf Debug steht, aber auf Release geht es nicht kaputt, wie
dem auch sei, wir wollen das ja eh nicht so schnell haben, aber kaputt gehen sollte es
eigentlich nicht, das sollte eigentlich volle Pulle, wir unreffen bestimmt irgendwas, was
schon kaputt ist oder so, Triggered a Breakpoint, ja welcher Breakpoint auch immer, jetzt ich
meine es ist ja geil, wenn es eine Exception wirft, aber warum, Unref, ja Breakpoint, habe
ich halt keine Ahnung, ok, wahrscheinlich machen wir hier irgendwie irgendwas blödes,
beim Unref kackt er ab, kackt er beim Unref ab, das ergibt ja überhaupt keinen Sinn, habe
ich das vielleicht in der falschen Reihenfolge irgendwie, ah V-Frame 3, ne ich dachte das
ist das neue 3, Moment, das sind unterschiedliche Dinger,
wartet mal kurz, so wieder da,
ich brauche gar nicht Unref, liegt es denn, wir gucken mal ob es überhaupt am Unref liegt,
ja ohne Unref geht es, allerdings ist mein Ram gleich voll, wenn es so weiter geht, Moment
wie mache ich das denn jetzt, jetzt stoßen meine krassen C-Pointer Skills an die Grenzen,
der möchte einen Pointer haben, also ein Pointer zu einem Pointer auf Frame, ich habe allerdings
nur einen Pointer auf Frame zu bieten, was mache ich denn jetzt, Leute haben wir nicht
irgendeinen der hier, der Patrick, der so eine krasse C-Owner, was mache ich denn jetzt,
also das geht, ok mal probieren wir aus, und, und, ey das wäre lustig wenn das geht, aber
das glaube ich nicht, ne, was a V-Frame, jetzt ist es richtig getippt, aber das ist dann
immer noch kein Pointer zum Pointer oder, ha, ha, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
Ja, an der stelle
Ich habe keine ahnung was ja interessant finde dass er das im release modus nicht macht
also mit anruf hat sie im release modus funktioniert
was ich interessant finde anruf ist doch eigentlich das richtige im release modus
funktioniert er doch auch was hat er im debug mod für schmerzen damit er
gut wisst ihr was wir machen wir native code debugging an aber schon
doch
ja das ist halt die frage ob der constructor das hier auch so macht
kann man jetzt nicht reingucken aber wahrscheinlich ja aber hier
irgendeine logik drinne die fail ist wisst ihr was wartet mal wir machen jetzt was anders
wir rennen dann jetzt mal nichts wir rennen dann jetzt mal nichts
gucken ob der ob der ob der decoder jetzt läuft
ne guck mal der decoder kackt schon ab warum ach so ja weil 100 elemente voll sind
ich fühle das ding mal hier drin
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass man das hier irgendwie
siehst du das richtig komplett startet in dem fall schon das ist einfach ein rapper
um diese um halt die zähle library von ffm pack
ja einfach ein pack ist zäge schwimmel
you can use frame anwärm oder to clear der donation sound poggers
1 euro 23 vom huru boss seine konungstiere sind immer interessant
das ist wenn es dir gefällt sehr sehr nice
da musst du das objekt auch pinnen weiß ich nicht ob ich das pinnen muss
ich dachte pinnen muss ich nur wenn ich quasi irgendwelche managed zu native
geschichten mache was ich jetzt an der stelle gar nicht mache ich mache unter
haum im prinzip alles unsafe native
natürlich ein beispiel wie das verwenden
da machen wir das jetzt doch mal so also wir waren jetzt in frame
das funktioniert
interessant
warum funktioniert das so und anders nicht ich meine das ist ok was machen
die denn in dem konstrukt davon muss das muss man auch github autogrenen
ffm pack und a v frame da muss man nachgucken die da unter hau unter der
hau bing was anderes machen ja ich mache auch acht ach so ich mache
ich das ist das package obendrüber ich mache nur ich mache nur 3 gerade das
funktioniert und wir liegen auch nichts und no leaks probieren das jetzt noch
mal anders rum
warum hat er hier irgendwelche schmerzen mit ich meine das müsste die lokal von
der funktion sein ok sind wir ja auch weiterhin
ok das problem ist anscheinend nur wenn ich das andere das funktioniert auch
ok das ist prinzipiell prinzipiell ist alles gut das problem tritt nur auf wenn
ich das von der anderen seite aus mache das denn
das ist entweder
das ist irgendwie in der threading geschichte was ich mir eigentlich
vorstellen kann oder die adressen stimmen einfach nicht
allerdings merkwürdig
ok warte mal ich brauche den frame hier brauche ich den danach brauche ich
nicht mehr
ich meine wir geben einfach den wir speichern uns einfach den pointer
da drin das geht natürlich auch aber eigentlich will ich kein anzelf zeug
rausgeben ok ich habe da alle die idee leute wir machen weil ich will
eigentlich hier in meiner form kann anzelf zeug verwenden ich will das
ganze anzelf zeug hier drin machen ich habe die idee wir machen jetzt noch
public-class-frame der kriegt ein av-frame av-frame
was hat er für schmerzen achso
wir können es auch noch anders machen wir können dann in point of
also ja wir reppen den camp noch mal in der eigenen frame klasse da müssen wir
da keine anzelf zeug rausgehen irgendwie so probieren aus gerade das so von von
der idee funktioniert was programmiert eigentlich programmieren in gif in gif
viewer also der tut ganz schön schnell das gif das ist als ergänzung zu meinem
overlay hier weil das wpf giftzeug so langsam ist guck wenn du hier drauf
klickst hast den klick gehört wie lange das dauert das ist der schnellste gift
player der welt hier da funktioniert er nur im release modus im debug modus nicht
es macht mich echt fertig jetzt was das vielleicht liegt am debugger das liegt
am debugger wenn er die bagger attached ist dann spackts rum wenn er die bagger
nicht attached ist dann spackts nicht rum liegt es am native code die baggen
ne also mit attach dem debugger spinns ok dann ist das ich glaube gar nicht dass
mein coder irgendwie probleme hat aber aber wir machen das trotzdem mit der
eigenen klasse
so und dann kriegen wir jetzt hier in den av frame so überlegen wir mal das
haben wir es machen also einen av frame probier das jetzt mal so frame
suppose weil das ist eigentlich das was was ich ursprünglich ursprünglich
vorhatte also ich wollte eh eine eine klasse dafür machen dass ich kein
anzeif zeug rausgeben muss weil fix fix wie ging da kram noch mal so na fix da
musste man quasi sagen es wird doch da dran liegen
av frame steinchen pointer geschiss jetzt für schmerzen
also anzeif nehmen aber nicht anzeif machen anzeif anzeif ja ja ich habe
kein if kein kein kein debug ifs irgendwo drin also nicht dass ich nicht
dass ich wüsste anzeif fix so das also was was was können wir in unserer frame
klasse sinnvolles geben das ist eh was was ich noch machen wollte sondern
properties brauchen wir wir brauchen in pointer data hier wird er mir
wahrscheinlich wird er meck wieder meckern wenn ich sage frame data null
das mag er wahrscheinlich nicht
ne das muss anzeif sein also sprich brauchen wir hier nun jetzt
get return das da brauchen wir was jetzt also anzeif moment ein rückung ein
rückung anzeif anzeif so gut wenn ich mag wird gekastet klar easy cast easy
life so dann brauchen wir noch in pitch brauchen wir noch frame line size war
das so ok das müsste doch eigentlich jetzt schon reichen so und die blogging
collection ist kein av frame mehr sondern nur dann frame
und hier ist es ein new frame falls das jetzt klappt hat der freund was von fix
geschrieben hat doch recht gehabt das package kann weiter anreffen ach so ja
klar das gibt es ja nicht so weil frame ist jetzt ja einen ab breite breite
dings da breite höhe brauchen wir noch ganz natürlich funktionieren
witz und heights wisst ihr wo ich übels bock drauf hätte leute also nicht jetzt
aber wo ich gerade gerade so bauchgefühl gerade so unbewusst dran
gedacht hat wo ich übels bock drauf hätte das ist ich würde jetzt gerne mit
dem fall mit mw2 spielen auf der 360 so ohne scheiß das ist mir grad so
eingefallen aber liebsten würde ich mich jetzt einloggen xbox party chat alter
war xbox party chat geil nicht diese verkackte scheiße da ja
stunden aber den krams gespielt außerdem waren wir da noch jünger
wobei es ist nicht so dass ich mir großartig alt vorkomme in der richtung
aber das wäre also
so witz viele witz und so viele heights noch mehr das ist jetzt einfach nur auf
frame data das haben wir schon gewerbt ich bin mal gespannt ob der shit
funktioniert er so jetzt muss es erst mal funktionieren und für memory liegen
jetzt wie verrückt die memory liegen ordentlich 2 gigabyte ram schon weg
bärm in your face noch mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert frame despose scheiße
alter was ist das für eine kacke
voll auf den sack
mega auf den sack dass es nicht funktioniert
aber wie ging das free kann ich mal tippen er free
frem frem frem frem ich kann jetzt schreiben av frem frem
ne ne das mag nicht ich weiß woran das liegt ich habe eine idee ich habe nie
das liegt überhaupt nicht an den referenzen das liegt hier dran
das liegt 100 pro hier irgendwo dran ich sag es euch der das rumgesiege ist
nicht richtig was ich hier mache weil ich guck mal das kackt ab genau ziemlich
genau nachdem es einmal durch ist
mein gesiege ist falsch alles kackt wischel studio noch ab oder was
guck das kackt mehr oder weniger direkt mein ich ich sieke falsch das das wird
sein dass es fehlt noch was oder sowas
so ist es anders an der stelle
fast das ist einfach nur verzögert haben
ich werde mit euch ich sieke falsch
ich habe das so irgendwie mach einfach try catch drauf wahrscheinlich wird das
sogar funktionieren aber dann auf jeden fall in den memory
liegt drinnen
ich muss mal suchen ich habe bestimmt irgendwo was wo ich mal ein stream
resettet habe ich ich suche noch mal ich suche noch mal danach siegfeil position
ffmpeg format kontext sieg
stream resett
einfach nicht sieg nur die datei selbst storm ja das ist es muss gehen man muss
mit immer muss doch an anfangen kommen
mehr flo so was mache ich nicht also sagen wir so dass mit dem mit dem selbst
mit dem mit dem storm das ist eine sache die ich vielleicht noch
mache aber ich will wissen wie ich ordentlich siege
position
afv kodak flasch buffers kann man gleich ausprobieren
was als letzten parametern vier
wenn sie mal lustig wie interaktiv die ganzen streben dann werden wenn ich mir
irgendwann hat weiter weiß das schon klar am anfang abgekackt
stimmt doch irgendwas net
ich spare mir jetzt mal kurz das disposender kackte auf jeden fall nicht
mehr ab aber mein ram ist halt relativ schnell voll
ok also nach was
könnte man dann noch mal suchen interessantes so was der overflow also
was was ist eigentlich was wir machen ffmpeg
besetzt dream auf leicht pizream
Speed Stream
Gibt es da irgendwas?
FFF Video Stream
Sieg feil
So und da muss rein der komische kontext hier wieder
Kontext
Index auf stream null
Smalls timestamp null
Lange tage timestamp macht der da stream stream
Duration null bin ich ja mal gespannt ob der scheiß funktioniert
Ups was vergessen
Moment ich habe was vergessen was habe ich vergessen
Null min null
Tage timestamp null
Null max timestamp. Der jetzt aber na
Da war es jetzt ein akte
Gehen wir memory liegen immer noch das tolles aber das ist ja klar
Okay jetzt gucken wir auf wird es pausen dürfen
Aha ich sag's euch hab's euch doch gesagt wir haben falsch gesiegt
Das ist zwar kein richtiges deutsch ich weiß zwar nicht was wir falsch gesiegt haben, aber wir haben falsch gesiegt
Das ist halt einfach so wir wieder komplett wir alter komplett durch
Und wir memory liegen auch nicht wirklich oder vielleicht ein paar kilobyte, aber das
Nee wir memory liegen nicht
Guck mal hier 1200 fps gif animation
Was gesiegt bedeutet das ist ganz schlecht eingeläut gesucht
Ich meine damit hier das hier guck
Sieg also suchen
Und so gesiegt
Ich meine damit hier das hier guck sieg also suchen und zwar also so wie ich das jetzt verstehe macht er an der stelle folgendes
Hier ich öffne ja hier die datei warte mal
Hier guck mal hier öffne ich ja die datei also meine meine bilddatei öffne ich ja hier
Open input im fad steht die bilddatei drin und dann habe ich hier eine schleife wo ich quasi
Inhalte aus der datei auslese irgendwann bin ich am ende end of file
Und dann muss ich dass ich weiter lesen kann wieder an den anfang sieken also wieder an den anfang springen
Also ich muss quasi den anfang suchen
Also ich gebe quasi wieder auf position 0 zurück das ist ja natürlich sehr umständlich bei in dem c sharp stream würde ich sagen bei dem c sharp memory stream
würde ich sagen
position gleich 0 und er wäre am anfang
Aber so einfach ist das jetzt natürlich nicht
AV format sieg feil
Warum ich doppelt machen muss weiß ich nicht
Weil stack overflow das gesagt hat
Kannst du ein video von mir kurz anschauen und sagen wie es ist und ob ich das video schneller machen soll oder oder nicht
Es ist ein tutorial video für einen bot
Einer hat mich gefragt ob ich ein anleitungsvideo machen möchte für den bot was ich auch gemacht habe was für mich war eher zu langsam die
Aktionen und was für ein bot geht es denn
gibt er viele bots
Aktuelle ssd temp
wie liest man das aus naja das geht das das das hittet ja gar nicht immer die ssd das hängt ja schon in einem fall ist im cash oder so
Kommt mir trotzdem nicht ganz richtig was du probiert ob man beides machen muss nö ich habe das stack overflow kopiert
Nö muss man nicht
Man muss nicht beides machen jetzt gucken wir mal ob das andere auch gehen würde
Okay, man braucht nur das erste
Man braucht nur das erste
Ne, okay, man braucht nur das erste man braucht nur das erste wie es aussieht
Oder auch nicht vielleicht braucht man doch beides
Man braucht auch beides zwar eben nur glück oder
Oder nicht was war fuck
Man braucht doch nur das erste
Man braucht doch nur das erste spektrum aber wir müssen mal ein kleines wir müssen mal neu bilden so und jetzt noch mal
Ne es reicht es reicht nicht
Man muss beides machen
Kackt ab wenn man nur eins davon hat
Kackt ab wenn man nur eins davon macht ab und zu mal so kackt es nicht ab
Sehr interessant
Sehr interessant 1200 fps die sekunde wohl gewerkt
Ja aber richtig cool dass es
So schnell ist ich mein mit gecashten bildern ist es mit sicherheit noch eine ganze ecke schneller
So schnell ist ich meine mit gecashten bildern ist es mit sicherheit noch eine ganze ecke schneller keine frage
Gehe ich mal gehe ich mal von aus dass es
Mit gecashten bilder noch eine ganze ecke schneller ist
Ich meine wir könnten es mal ausprobieren
Da müssten wir quasi wir könnten uns quasi die bilder hier in der zwischenspeichern
Das können wir mal probieren gucken mal einfach nur mal testen was es für einen unterschied macht wenn man die bilder zwischenspeichern
Eine möglichkeit um die frame rate zu setten warum soll ich denn die frame rate setten das auch die frame rate messen
Du siehst ein memory leak wo ist es zeige ja private list frame
Frames sagen wir zwei einmal frames klein einmal frames groß
Mal gucken ob das ob das so funktioniert
Das jetzt noch mal zu checken was es für ein performance unterschied macht zu cashen
Wenn du das programm jetzt startest geht es nach oben
Jetzt warum sollte ich hab da gar nichts gemacht
Das pendelt sich ein bei irgendwie um die 100 da liegt nix
Da liegt nix warum ist ein stirr die schild der playlist geht hier nicht mehr
Da liegt nix guck was als fehler hätte durchaus sein können
Und jetzt bitte das gift noch mit multis werden wir multis werden ja im prinzip schon
Wir werden das gift in dem einen und die grafik in dem anderen also mit die kone das gift in einem
Und trennen die grafik in dem anderen
So mal gucken wie viel das jetzt bringt mit gecashten frames
Okay so das heißt wir machen das wir breaken also wir gehen raus
Nachdem wir einmal durch den end of file und danach machen wir endlos zum testen
Endlos add frames von von dem ding
Oder wie machen wir das jetzt am besten
Wir gehen wir breaken wenn wir end of file sind wir haben uns alle files zwischen gespeichert
Doch wir machen das mit einer weile schlafen wir machen zwar frame wir machen c style cnt
So und dann sagen wir add frames add
Ich bin mal gespannt wie viel schneller das ist das lassen wir aber nicht so ich finde
das andere schon schöner
Wenn es direkt weil ich will ja gar nicht so viel ramp verbrauchen das ja eigentlich
sind ins weg der sache so add frame dann müssen wir quasi gucken
So und wenn das frame counter größer this frames count ist dann resetten wir frame counter
wieder auf null
Das jetzt so funktioniert bin ich mal gespannt
Nein das habe ich falsch gemacht
Irgendwo irgendwo ist meine meine logik fail
größer gleich doch es müsste wahrscheinlich größer gleich sein
Auch nicht
Wo ist das problem
Wo ist das Problem
Achso ich sollte die frames nicht das pausen das wäre vielleicht ganz praktisch
Moment was stimmt jetzt an meiner logik nicht ich meine das kackt schon mal nicht mehr
ab das ist schon mal gut
Irgendwo ist es null immer null
Ach ich mache es pro durche auf alter bin ich dumm guck mal
Richtig dumm
Nicht der kack noob
Guck mal hier bam gleich mal
Doppelte bis dreifache anzahlen auch wieder schwankt es liegt es liegt da da heftig liegt
es
Warum liegt das denn
Das sollte jetzt aber eigentlich nicht liegen
Das soll hä wo kommt das memory leak jetzt bitte schon her ich höre hier doch auf einzulesen
Wo kommt denn das her
Das muss jetzt mal einer erklären wo das herkommt
Musst du nicht alten frames aus der liste remove
Ja das mache ich ja hier
Das ist immer wieder in cache eingelesen
Warum liegt das denn jetzt
Es können ja auch gar nicht mehr als 100 rein
Oder Moment ich habe das limit raus genommen
Ich habe das limit raus genommen für die blocking collection
Der schreibt wirklich jetzt unendlich viel da rein
Krass äh hau verkackt
Hallo andi unter aller sau
Was ist ein memory leak
Ja warte mal
Boah poggers gecachede bilder macht was aus
Schauts euch an
Gecachede bilder ist das nochmal
Da ist der schnellste gif player quasi noch schneller geworden
Sind wir schon bei fast 5000 fps
Oh mein gott
Also ähm
A memory leak ist eigentlich relativ einfach erklärt
Das was der flow96 sagt ist so schon gar nicht verkehrt
Wobei das nicht den kern trifft
Wenn der ram verbrauch permanent steigt
Die frage ist natürlich warum steigt der ram verbrauch immer weiter an
Und
In sprachen wie sagen wir mal c
Dort wo du dich um die speicherverwaltung selbst kümmern musst
Ist eigentlich auch das einzige wo memory leaks auftreten können
Und warum ich in c sharp memory leaks habe
Ist ähm weil ich eben die c library verwende
Im prinzip ist eine memory leak ganz einfach damit erklärt
Wenn du speicher anforderst
Aber den speicher nicht wieder zurück gibst
Das ist in memory leak
Wenn ich jetzt sage betriebssystem gibt mir speicher
Ich möchte was damit machen
Kriege ich keine ahnung
Ein mb speicher
Und ähm
Nächstes mal wenn ich was sage
Wenn ich was brauche
Betriebssystem ich brauche wieder ein mb speicher
Ohne dass ich den speicher jemals wieder
Äh sage hier kannst du wieder verwenden
Das ist in memory leak
Ja also sprich ich gebe einfach nicht den speicher wieder frei
Den ich mal angefordert habe ganz ganz simpel gesagt
Und was heißt ganz simpel gesagt
Genau das ist es
Du forderst speicher an und gibst die nicht wieder
Oder vergisst die wieder zurück zu geben
Und forderst weiteren an
Und dann leaks du halt quasi memory
Weil ja du hast es angefordert gibst das aber nie wieder zurück
Letztendlich führt eine memory leak aber nie dazu
Das was kaputt geht
Das schlimmste was passieren kann ist
Äh
Dass irgendwann mal out of memory gibt
Und du halt kein rammer kriegst
Oder dein programm abgeschossen wird
Das wahrscheinlich eher dein programm abgeschossen
Also eigentlich passiert nichts
Weil spätestens wenn dein programm beendet wird
Wird auch jeglicher speicher wieder eingesammelt
Den es jemals bekommen hat
Also sprich du kannst nur
Und das ist eine ganz wichtige geschichte
Die man sich merken muss
Du kannst nur memory leaken solange dein programm noch läuft
Das ist ja auch gerade der
Der effekt den man hat bei zeug
Was ein bisschen merkwürdig programmiert ist
Und z.B.
Am Anfang Battlefield 4
Dass man das
Teilweise nach 2-3 stunden neu starten musste
Weil das dann irgendwann 5GB gefressen hat
Oder so ram
Und durch den neustart vom game beendet sich der prozess
Das betriebssystem sammelt alle arbeitsspeicher wieder ein
Den es jemals diesen prozess gegeben hat
Das weiß es ja
Es wurde ja von ihm angefordert
Und sagt jawoll kann es wieder verwendet werden
Saito bar 3 man sieht es natürlich anders aus
Ja wir reden jetzt hier rein von user mode geschichten
Aber ich muss sagen hier dieser
Der player der ist richtig hübsch jetzt oder
Wir können es hier nochmal einrücken ein bisschen anders
Ich glaube wir machen das mal alles
Gucken ob das so besser aussieht wenn wir das alles auf eine ebene machen
Sieht es jetzt besser aus ich weiß nicht
Es sieht kürzer aus
Ich muss sagen ich finde den gift player eigentlich ganz hübsch jetzt
So wie er ist vor allem jetzt nachdem wir den frame nochmal
Quasi gekapselt haben
Finde ich den echt ganz ganz nett
Achso ja gut jetzt müssen wir noch ein sleep einbauen
Ok dann machen wir hier noch einen public
Wo ist man zwar nicht aber finde ich schöner
Stream index brauchen wir auch nicht
Ist immer 0
Können wir tatsächlich read only machen
Wir machen jetzt noch hier was
Und das setzen wir
Jetzt kriegen wir noch die fps
So jetzt werden wir das ganze nämlich ein bisschen begrenzen noch
Weil aktuell ist es ein bisschen viel
Gucken wir mal was der ganze spaß für cpu verursacht
Also wir brauchen gerade mal leppische 33% cpu last
Also quasi von einem 6 kerne lasten wir 2 kerne quasi komplett aus
Was auch irgendwie sinn ergibt dass wir 2 kerne komplett auslasten
Wir haben hier unseren thread der gifs decoded
Und wir haben hier unseren thread der wie verrückt rendert
Also das passt schon dass wir 2 kerne ziemlich gut auslasten
Und das ist ein beispiel halt für ein problem was sich super multithreaden lässt
So und wir werden jetzt mal sleepen
Wir sleepen jetzt allerdings nicht einfach random irgendwie
Sondern wir sleepen jetzt anhand der
Das ist hier decoder
Fps
Tausend
Durch fps
Dann müssten wir eigentlich die zeit oder
Die zeit in millisekunden haben die wir sleepen müssten
Er ist ein double
Ich will es ja in millisekunden
1 durch framerate ist ja 0, irgendwas
Ich will es ja in millisekunden es müsste so doch eigentlich passen
Oder ist jetzt genau falsch rum
Ne passt doch guck mal genau 25 fps so soll es sein
Das ist der alte gif player also man sieht 25 fps sind 25 fps
Wenn man sich das anguckt wird man verrückt
Mit der zeit das wird da jetzt voll schwindelig
Man sieht es ist nicht ganz synchron guck mal es läuft auseinander
Jetzt weiß man nicht was richtiger ist meins oder der wpf timer
Es läuft immer weiter auseinander
Mit dem timer könnte man das auch machen aber wir brauchen halt also wir bräuchten
halt einen sehr sehr präzisen timer
Also das wäre schon also mit mit einem timer den man auf
Da reicht noch nicht mal millisekunden
Also mal angenommen wir wollen was mit 60 fps haben
Dann bräuchten wir quasi 16,66 also irgendwie soweit wie es geht millisekunden
Die differenz der zyklen ja das muss man auch mal machen
Also und sprich wenn man es quasi nur mit 16 macht wird man ja irgendwie dann
Läuft man damit knapp unter 25 fps also müsste man
Ne mit knapp über 25 umso kürzer die zeit umso schneller
Knapp über 25 fps also bräuchte man irgendwie einen timer
Der halt auch wirklich hoch auflöst gibt es gibt es dort nicht mäßig so was
Timer intervall kann man kann man die intervall das muss man mal gucken
Wie sieht es mit sleep nanosekunden aus mikrosekunden aus
Es gibt es gibt das hier es gibt thread aber das ist nicht schön es gibt spin
Da kannst du irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob es sind nanosekunden ne das ist glaube
Ich irgendwie schleif ins intern schleifendurchgänge oder sowas
Wir können ja mal stackoverflow bemühen die scharp sleep nanosekunden
Wir können mal gucken was was task delay hat
Millisekunden millisekunden timespan wenn es den timespan frisst
Prokramierst du auch beruflich ja aber was anderes als hier
Allerdings verdiene ich nicht meine hauptsächliches kohler damit ich
Prokramiere auch sachen ich mache so das was man neudeutsch def obs nennt
Kann man hier nicht sagen new timespan also erst mal gucken ob das generell mit
dem delay wie macht man das jetzt wait nicht wirklich oder was hat man 40
Millisekunden verwirrungswunsch fps ne okay der task der task delay ist fail
der funktioniert nicht richtig also hier 60 fps funktionieren hier
60 fps ja und hier sieht man jetzt das halt der das nicht so ganz stimmt
hat es immer ein bisschen schwankt wie können wir denn das jetzt wie
sleept man dann hier ordentlich unter oder besser gesagt moment wie auf wie
gut auflösen sind dann die timer intervall system threading timer system
timer system windows ok was ist der unterschied dazwischen timer callback object state ok
der sieht kompliziert aus der kann bestimmt was period in millisekunden alles in millisekunden
es haben wir hier zu bieten intervall milliseconds als letztes haben die windows timer der kann
man hier gar nicht setzen intervall in millisekunden performance count das gibt es bestimmt schon
managt das ist da muss irgendwas ich wein ich hätte eine ganz blöde ideen
ah flow das hast du gut beobachtet das kann man mal ausprobieren timer timer er akzeptiert
aber double das können wir echt mal ausprobieren also sprich dass man da jetzt 16,777 oder
ne was war es
noch mal gucken wie wir das jetzt machen also von der idee her müssen wir uns jetzt ja
die schleife hier schenken
und der render krempel müsste eigentlich da rein jetzt ne wenn ich das jetzt richtig
sehe es kann aber auch sein dass es voll verkacken ach so vielleicht sollte man mal starten start
da
30?
Warum 33?
Check ichs jetzt nicht?
Das Ding sollte doch...
33?
Warum 33?
Ich glaub der timet einfach nicht so genau.
Nee, der ist einfach nicht so genau der Timer, der ist schlecht.
Ich mein wir wollen jetzt hier alle 40 Millisekunden einen Tick haben und...
Hast du noch ein Sleep drin?
Nee.
Ja, aber wenns mit 40 schon halt geht, Clocks HD...
Also...
Der Timer ist irgendwie nicht sonderlich precision-mäßig.
Das Drawn geht schnell, das Drawn braucht doch keine so viel, das Drawn braucht nix.
Ja, aber mein Code braucht keine...
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Wenn man weiß, dass es ja ohne Timer gehts ja auch schnell.
Also, ne?
Das ist ja nicht so...
Also mit nem Sleep, mit nem normalen Sleep funktionierts ja.
Also daran kann es schonmal nicht liegen.
Nee, also mit dem Timer klappt das nicht.
Ich hab aber ne ganz blöde andere Idee.
Pass mal auf.
Ist bei GIFs nicht die Zeit zwischen den einzelnen Bildern in der GIF selbst hinterlegt?
Das kann durchaus sein.
Hast du einen Grund warum du auf Englisch schreibst?
W-w-w-w-wo schreib ich auf Englisch?
Meinst du hier drinnen?
Ja, Sounds Code schreibt man dann immer auf Englisch.
Ja, aber Leute, das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Lass es mal ne Millisekunde dauern, wie das hier Ding.
Das kann aber trotzdem nicht sein, dass der Timer auf einmal anstatt 60,
obwohl ich die Zeit für 60 FPS angegeben auf einmal 33 hat.
Achso, Tastaturlayout. Hab ich nicht, ich hab das Tastaturlayout auf Deutsch.
So, also wir machen jetzt mal sowas hier.
Das ist natürlich der Hardcore-Ansatz, sowas zu machen.
Also, wir machen jetzt irgendwie sowas wie...
Wir machen jetzt irgendwie sowas wie,
Also Wir Machen Jetzt IrGendwie so was wie
Weil True und dann dann dann Slippen wir IrGendwie Zwischen Zwischendurch
IrGendwie sowas das funktioniert das wird Auf Jeden fall Funktionieren
Kann man das Kann man das IrGendwie mit Detail Machen oder so
Obwohl wir haben hier oben doch wir haben hier oben doch schon in daytime gesetzt start start time
Aber ich probiere das Jetzt Mal Aus
Start
Obbei Ne mit daytime Komme ich da Wahrscheinlich nicht weiter
Mit stopwatch mit stopwatch Können wir da IrGendwas Machen
Mit stopwatch
Was war eine Image Instanz dort den aktuellen frame index und last update Millisekunden
Im image update Leuchten wir gerade nicht ein
Ach so du checkst vorher ob es zeit zum updaten ist
Du machst das Du machst das nicht alles hier in so einem riesen durchlauf sondern du checkst
quasi so nach dem motto gibt es ein update ist es zeit zu updaten und wenn es Zeit zu updaten ist
Damit Gemalt und gestoort
Ticks
Ticks brauchen wir
Okay die meinen das Ernst Ticks
Wie lang ist denn ein Tick ein paar nanosekunden oder so
Ticks sind nicht Millisekunden Ticks ist irgendwas mit nanosekunden oder so
Ticks mal 100 sind nanosekunden oder sehe ich das hier richtig
Ticks mal 100 sind nanosekunden okay
Microseconds würden wir schon reichen
Aha das ist ja nice Ticks per Millisekund
Aha das ist das ist gut stack overflow heute sind wir richtig stack overflow driven
Ich will es jetzt einfach mal rauskriegen ob das so so funktioniert würde
So wie jetzt gucken wir gerade wieder 140 leute zu wie ich keine ahnung
Habt wie wir es hier ordentlich warten können gibt es gibt es nicht vielleicht einen sie schabt
Gibt es das wäre mir natürlich am allerliebsten muss ich den ganzen wait schiess nicht selber
machen
Das hat doch bestimmt schon irgendeiner programmiert
Github sie schabt timer high high precision timer in dotnet zack
easy wie macht der das
ja mit dem windows timer das können wir auch machen was sind das für eine für eine win
mdl
media timer muss ja genau sein
Dann machen wir das doch damit
Obbei mich ja doch interessieren würde wie man sowas hier hinkriegen
Probieren wir das mal mit dem windows timer ich glaube das ist die bessere variante
Warum ist es hier schwarz weil man weiß nicht
gibt es aber schon fertige projekte
da gibt es ein paar
Ok wir machen das mal wie hier also ich finde das hier klingt gut
Time set event
Wir klauen uns jetzt mal hier den aufruf von ihm wie er das wie er das gemacht hat
Also wir klauen uns das nicht wir holen uns die api definition raus
Ja das nämlich
Gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert wir rennen wir rennen dann mal gerade nichts
Wir gucken einfach nur mal ob das geht
Das sieht von der von der von der auflöser von von der methode relativ simpel aus von
der signatur her
Also set time ne wie hieß der kram set time set event
So und dann sagen wir kleine stars diese promi frauen sind unter ein meter sechzig
Oh ja das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen von gofeminin.de
Milliseconds
Moment
Ich will keine Milliseconds
Obwohl doch Milliseconds mit Komma ist ok
Was sagt die Microsoft hilfe seite dazu
So was sagt denn die Microsoft hilfe seite dazu
In Milliseconds ich will es doch nicht in Milliseconds haben
Warum ist das scheiß auch wieder in Milliseconds
Alter geht mir das auf den keks jetzt
Was query performance
Oh ja das ist schön das wollen wir haben
Da machen wir einfach jetzt eine wildschleife und gucken einfach
Warum nennt man das
New delay wenn es Milliseconds sind weil das Microsoft ist wahrscheinlich für unsigned
Weil es ein unsigned ist
Ich weiß dass du es gleich schon gesagt hast
qpc und qpf
Query performance
Die Frequenz in der sich der performance counter update oder was also dass man sieht
wie groß die sprünge sind zwischen den countern oder wie darf man das verstehen
Query performance counter
Jetzt Achtung schön das neue C sharp 7 feature
Out bar counter
Nächster mit extra variabler anlegen und jetzt counter ausgehen
Aha jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Butschend
Achso und das heißt, hiermit sehe ich quasi den Counter, der sich erhöht. Nur mal so,
dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe. Ich habe hier einen Counter, ich weiß allerdings nicht
wie genau wie lang eine einheit ist wenn ich wissen will wie lange eine einheit ist dann muss ich hierhin gucken
Oder ist es ein timestamp in in was
Mikrosekunden okay
Kann, wir können, wir ausprobieren
Beruf, beruflich mache ich das in vielen sprachen
Also was natürlich
Wenn, man, ein, bisschen mit inox zu tun hat immer der fall ist es
Irgendwelche shells, ich mache ganz gerne in ruby was wenn es nicht schnell sein muss
In groovy habe ich auch ein paar sachen gebastelt schon wenn es geht dort net mit dort net core geht ja auf linux mittlerweile auch
Mal auch die eine oder andere java script frontend geschichte wenn es sich nicht vermeiden lässt
paar sachen also am liebsten mache ich eigentlich was in ruby wenn es nicht auf performance ankommt ruby und dort net ist für
Mich so auf einer also die scharp und ruby ist für mich so auf einer einer ebene
okay
Also das heißt nur also wie wir machen jetzt jetzt mal ganz billig wir machen jetzt einen schleif und prägen die schleife sobald wir
quasi
40 millisekunden oder sag, man, mal 16 16, irgendwas
millisekunden gewartet haben irgendwie
oder besser gesagt
16000 mikrosekunden
Aber was noch sie also gucken, wir machen
die performance counter
Ich habe irgendwas im hals so und dann brauchen wir jetzt noch das andere das heißt dann brauchen wir jetzt noch
die gleiche signatur hat
Okay, das müssen wir nur einmal querien ich auch gerade sehen
Ich weiß es gar nicht wie was nennen sollen query performance frequency
Und war
Timespan
Was machst du dort gerade ich bastel ein transparentes gif overlay
Für meinen
Neen bort weil das standard wpf overlay wie du hier siehst wenn ich drauf klicke
Viel zu langsam ist jetzt ja du klickst
zack
klick
zack klick
zack viel zu langsam bei kleinen bei kleinen gifs geht es ganz schnell aber ich habe jetzt was eigenes gebastelt was viel schneller ist
das spielt gifs mit
4273 fps ab
Was kein mensch braucht so jetzt gucken wir gerade wie wir am besten warten auf das nächste nächste mal wo wir rennen mussten
Ganz wichtig nicht einfach fps sondern fps in der sekunde
So performance counter
Sonst hängt er nach einmal rennen dann hängt er jetzt hier
So
Das bedeutet doch jetzt nur mal so von der idee also wenn ich jetzt hier einmal ausgebe
Quasi den den den den die timespan also das da
Ist quasi die zeit
Zwischen zwei tix von diesen performance counter oder
Oder habe ich das denn jetzt
Frequenzie oder ne moment moment moment das ist das nee das ist wie wie wie schnell der updated oder
Gibt es natürlich noch 2000
Genau counter durch frequency ok was kommt dann da am ende raus
Nennen wir es nicht timespan
Frequenzie das ist ist das eine sekunde
Das ist pro sekunde
Das ist pro sekunde ne
Aha okay das oh das ist aber echt interessant
Das ist sehr interessant
Lange mikrosekunden ja
Also ganz, so ganz habe ich es jetzt aber noch nicht gecheckt, wie wir das machen.
Warte mal, also sprich, was sehe ich denn jetzt überhaupt?
Das update sich einmal in der Sekunde, das ist die, der Counter, der geht permanent rauf
und das geteilt durch die, durch die Frequency, so also das bedeutet jetzt haben wir hier
die Frequency, was, war, das ist kein JavaScript, war, wie ist das aus, was ist das, was ist
das?
Wie check ich das nicht, was ich was, was ich da jetzt eigentlich für eine Zeit habe.
Also wenn ich das jetzt habe, dann das jetzt in der Sekunde ist.
Also es leuchtet mir ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Was soll das jetzt genau sein?
Der Query das hier am Anfang, dann speichert er sich das irgendwo, wo speichert er sich
das da, das nicht hier oben speichern, das ist im Prinzip ein bisschen was ich oben beim
FPS Counter auch mache, oder?
Also brauche ich hier sowas wie, ne, hä?
Ich will im Prinzip doch einfach nur wissen, ob ich jetzt schon 60 Millisekunden gewartet
oder in dem Fall 16 Millisekunden, also.
Äh, wie macht man das da draus?
Scheiße ich sie scharf stark von C++, ja.
Was, Double Counter, ich kann sowas nicht Copy Paste, ich muss das jetzt erstmal checken,
was ich da habe.
Jaja, dass es die Millisekunden sind, das ist mir schon klar, aber ich will doch einfach
glaube ich mehr als, ich muss die zwei Sachen miteinander vergleichen.
Also ich muss mir einfach, ich muss mir einmal Start holen, Start Counter, so und im Prinzip
muss ich doch jetzt eigentlich nur gucken, ob ich jetzt, ob das hier größer, Start Counter,
so und hier muss ich jetzt dazu rechnen, was ich brauche zur Zahl für Millisekunden.
Also irgendwie keine Ahnung, wie auch immer, wie viel das ist.
So, wenn ich das jetzt dazu rechne, dürfte es dann wieder bei einer Sekunde sein, jaja,
das sieht so aus, ne nicht plus Frequency.
Easy peasy.
Wir können mal gucken was passiert, genau auskennfuchs, sowas in der richtung hab ich
auch gar nicht, wenn man die krams voneinander abzieht, da müsste ja was relativ kleines
rauskommen, genau, und das
die frequenzie ist ja nicht in millisekunden, irgendwie ist das der übelste brainfuck dieser
also projekt soll ich noch einmal
das ist das ist übelst ob die ecke
ich glaube ich habe heute schon zu lange vom rechner gesessen das zu checken
stimmt das jetzt?
ich glaube das jetzt irgendwie sind was ich da gebastelt habe
ja klar kann man es mit einem kleinen sleep ersetzen, das ist ja auch genau genug
aber ich glaube ich bin heute nicht in der lage sowas zu checken mehr, das ist echt wahnsinn
ich kann gerade keinen klaren gedanken fassen was so ein bisschen logik anbelangt
es war halt einfach schon zu lange rum gebastelt, ja ja das gif hat das gif hat 25 fps das ist easy
das war kein ding aber ich will ja trotzdem gucken wie ich konstante 60 fps hinkriege
das würde mich einfach mal interessieren
ja timer timer habe ich keinen gefunden der genau genug ist
ich mache jetzt mal kurz was
ich glaube die idee ist gar nicht so schlecht
ich mein von der idee her war das einfach richtig wenn mein counter größer ist als start counter
und jetzt halt hier quasi sowas wie plus 16 millisekunden in ticks so kann ich jetzt nicht
sagen okay frequency frequency ist das was pro sekunde frequency ist ticks also das frequency
ist ticks von diesem counter pro sekunde
das heißt was kommt da jetzt raus
ist das jetzt teilweise 16 millisekunden
ich will ich will rauskriegen wie viel frequency quasi 16 millisekunden also wie viele wie
viele ticks quasi 16 millisekunden entsprechen
das bedeutet ich muss gerade was ausprobieren
einfach mal gucken wie viele ungefähr rauskommen muss jetzt
also irgendwas in dieser größe
ich kann heute nichts mehr umrechnen ich bin nicht in der lagen irgendwas zu rechnen
so also irgendwas um 50.000 müsste rauskommen deswegen mit dem dreh und das ist auch relativ
schwer
Wenn ich 60 mal wenn ich wenn ich quasi weiß das ist pro sekunde und ich weiß das ist
pro sekunde da kann ich das doch eigentlich durcheinander teilen oder
oder mein von der idee müsste es doch so was hier sein aber aus irgendwelchen gründen ist es das nicht oder oder ist es das doch
was kann man auch machen das dauert auch keinen großen unterschied
so kann unterschied
so genau das gleiche im endeffekt weil es beides ist auch beides pro sekunde das müsste doch im
prinzip das müsste doch eigentlich genau das gleiche sein
ist doch
das habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht ich kann echt nicht mehr denken heute
ich blicke immer durch gerade
ich will doch keinen so großen unterschied machen
das ist irgendeine konversion geschichte weil ich meine im prinzip das da ich das jetzt davon
handeintrag geht es ja auch aber das warum geht das vorher nicht
auf 9000
das ist irgendeine konversion geschichte
ok das hatte ich doch vor fünf minuten schon was ist denn jetzt daran verkehrt
das ist doch von der logik her ok das müsste
ja das
sieht nicht so aus wie man normalerweise performt
ich hab, ich hab auch keine ahnung wie man das macht
wisst ihr was?
da muss ich mir noch mal Gedanken drüber machen
wie wir das am besten machen
hier drinnen zu sleepen ist eh keine
sondern nicht clevere Idee
aber ich glaub wir können es jetzt erst mal kurz
als erstes mal
für heute können wir das so lassen
ich mein prinzipiell funktioniert es ja
na?
25 fps gif
passt
start counter form rendering hole
ok, machen wir
ich mach jetzt, ich mach jetzt alles
ich kann heute eh nur mal richtig denken
du warst aber schon vor, vor dem Durchgang, ne?
pro Durchgang
hm
jetzt ist es sogar, jetzt ist es sogar ein ticken zu schnell
aber das liegt daran
wahrscheinlich, dass ich hier
Komma-Stellen verliere irgendwie, ne?
weil mir das jetzt ja mal einer erklären muss
was hat er denn jetzt, was macht er denn hier wieder für conversion-dinger
zack
damit kann ich leben
so
das sieht doch jetzt ziemlich gleich aus, oder?
gifs übertaktet, yeah
ja, thera fox, das klingt logisch, ich muss mir noch mal Gedanken drüber machen
von der logik her müsste es doch stimmen, weil ich da gewastelt habe, oder?
ich meine, das GIF sieht jetzt auch schön SYNC aus
das ist präzise genug
das ist nicht lang
guck mal mal, wir gucken mal wie lange das dauert, so ein, ein, einmal malen
ja, und das stimmt, die Trot-Zeit wird tatsächlich abgezogen, weil wir den Krams am Anfang nehmen
da hab ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht am Anfang
also, wo fangen wir an? das eigentliche Malen ist ja hier
start
painter, paint
bis da, würde ich sagen, ne?
hier oben müssen wir übrigens, äh, ein bisschen reset müssen wir an der Stelle machen
ne, nicht reset, stopp
so, ähm, gucken wir mal
wir haben Millisekunden, so, und danach haben wir reset
dauert keine Millisekunde
guck mal, das braucht nichts im Endeffekt
in Ticks sind 100 Nanosekunden irgendwie an der Stelle, ja?
das, das Drawn braucht nichts
das braucht wirklich unter einer Millisekunde, ja?
hier, guck mal
unter einer halben Millisekunde braucht das Ganze
das Drawn, das ist nichts im Endeffekt
das ist wirklich nichts
eigentlich könnten wir anstatt, wir könnten auch den Stopwatch-Timer da unten nehmen, ne?
was, wenn das Drawn länger dauern würde, wie lang würden dann 3D-Spiele dauern?
lange, das muss schnell gehen
ich mein, wir Drawn ja hier im Endeffekt auch nichts, ne?
ne, ne, das macht schon selbst alles
ähm, wir machen hier am Endeffekt auch nichts, ne?
wir haben hier oben ein paar komische Scale und ähm, na, Transparenzgeschichten
und ähm, dann malen wir noch einen FPS-Counter und ein Bild
also, das ist im Endeffekt ja nichts
bringt das, das, das geht aus dem Bild raus, oder?
das geht aus dem Bild raus
seht ihr das?
den lassen wir mal
20, äh, 22 Pixels weiter unten starten
ja, jetzt ist es besser
wobei, nicht weiter unten, 20 weiter, weiter rechts starten
ja
oder?
ne, ich glaub oben klippt er
oben klippt er
ja, oben hat er ein bisschen geklippt
so, machen wir das Ganze jetzt mal mit 5 FPS
rechts und oben klippt er oben, oben klippt er noch ein bisschen, oder?
oben klippt er noch, aber es könnte sogar sein, dass das im Bild so ist
machen wir mal oben ganz viel Abstand
ah, ne, ok, noch mal 30 oben
muss ich mal gucken, warum das oben überhaupt klippt
ja, so ist gut
hier oben, das ist, das ist im Bild so, dass der oben kurz geklippt ist
wunderbar, zack, bam
sehr schön
das ist doch nice, das gefällt, ja
durchklicken
GIF am Start
und, ich mein, guck mal
wir brauchen jetzt 90 MB
machen wir mal, stellen wir das Ganze mal wieder um auf Window Only
Window Only, stellen wir das Ganze um, Release Mode
wir brauchen ziemlich genau 88 MB
oder auch nicht
80, was für ne komische Anzeige
angeblich haben wir 80, aber hier oben ist 9,8
also wir brauchen 80 MB im Vergleich zu 850
und es startet übel schnell
also wenn man sich überlegt, das, guck mal, es startet jetzt die ganze, das ganze Programm startet jetzt
das ganze Programm startet schneller und zeigt das GIF an, als das andere
jetzt nehmen wir mal ein großes GIF, was beim anderen Probleme macht
z.B.
Brain, irgendwas mit Brain
Mindblown heißt das Ding hier, Mindblown, das GIF brauchen wir jetzt noch
Ups, jetzt hab ich es gelöscht
so lange Dateifahne
ich hab mich irgendwo verschrieben
und auch übelst flüssig im Vergleich zum anderen
wir könnten noch, das Bilderscalen könnten wir noch ein bisschen schöner machen
weil hier sieht er besser aus
fehlt da ein bisschen was
oder ich glaub mein Scaling ist nicht ganz so sinnvoll
mein Scaling ist nicht ganz richtig würde ich sagen
mein Scaling ist nicht so ganz korrekt
sagen wir mal so, hier ist er schöner skaliert
wobei Leute ohne Scheiß, ich würde fast eher sagen, mein Scaling sieht mir irgendwie
also von Abmaßen her scheint mir das aber
guck mal wie flüssig das hier ist, seht ihr das wie flüssig das ist und wie sehr es da rumleckt
wir können das noch mal ein bisschen ändern wie er das ganze macht, wir können jetzt mal hier
Nearest Neighbor ist das schlechteste von der Qualität hier mit dem Cubic, das ist glaube ich beste Quali
na guck jetzt sieht es auch gleich besser aus
es ist nicht ganz gleich groß guck mal, wir müssen nochmal einen anderen Hintergrund nehmen
guck mal es ist nicht ganz gleich groß, es ist ein bisschen, meinst du es ist ein bisschen kleiner
ich mein jetzt ist es gleich, jetzt ist es ungefähr gleich breit, aber das ist ein Stück höher
also das heißt bei mir fehlt ein Stückchen würde ich mal sagen
bei mir fehlen ein paar Pixels
ja Terra Fox guck ich mir an, ich kann heute nicht mehr mir großartige Gedanken zu machen
normalerweise ist das bestimmt eigentlich nichts schwieriges
hier fehlt oben und unten ein bisschen was, aber das passt schon
so nice, das können wir jetzt dann einbauen das nächste Mal
in das eigentliche Tool wofür wir das ganze gebastelt haben und dann dauern GIFs nicht mehr 3 Sekunden zum anzeigen
sind instant da, die PNGs könnten wir übrigens auch noch mit FFmpeg machen
sehr schön, gefällt mir
das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal
so Leute, genug für heute, der GIF-Player funktioniert ziemlich gut
sagen wir verlieren wir immer noch irgendwo Speicher, kann das sein, nee, der braucht einfach eine Weile bis alles geladen ist
guck mal, das ist ein riesen Unterschied, das fette GIF, komplett gecached, braucht 160 MB
wohingegen das in WPF 850 braucht, das ist schon ein Unterschied
nee, der Server ist da nicht dabei, insgesamt braucht das Zeug irgendwie 180 MB
das ISP.NET Core plus das WPF Fenster, aber sobald ein GIF geladen wird gehts hier irgendwie hoch auf 850, 900 oder so
also sagen wir mal, das GIF braucht 700, 700 braucht das GIF und das liegt einfach daran
wir können uns das hier grad nochmal angucken, guck mal, ich hab jetzt ein paar GIFs geladen, instant 2G voll, kann doch nicht sein
jetzt gehts wieder runter auf 760, guck mal, jetzt sind wir mal bei 760 und jetzt mach ich das GIF hier an
das GIF hat eine schlechte Position
guck, 1,1, also das ist ja schon besser, nee nicht ganz, es ist tatsächlich nicht ganz so viel, aber es ist ordentlich
also irgendwie 400 aus uns immer noch und ich glaube er hat auch nicht alle aus dem Garbage-Collector geschaufelt
also das ist nicht sonderlich optimiert, dieses WPF GIF Ding, da sind wir hier doch schon deutlich besser mit dabei, oder?
da sind wir schon deutlich besser mit dabei, 120 MB oder so
und wenn wir das ganze nicht cashen, das können wir jetzt gleich auch nochmal ausprobieren, wie viel wir dann haben
ich hoffe ich hab mir den Kram irgendwo gespeichert, sagen wir das übliche, rückgängig, rückgängig, rückgängig
rückgängig, rückgängig, rückgängig, wo hab ich mir gespeichert, den Scheiß, lol
wenn ich mich jetzt verdrücke ist alles weg, denke ich muss ihn nicht speichern, da
und wieder vorwärts, dafür hat man eigentlich ein Git oder sowas
soll mal gucken wie viel das ist, wenn ich es nicht cache, dann für 25 FPS reicht es natürlich immer noch
achso ich muss hier die Frames freen, sonst leaken wir
na guck, 118, das ist doch top, da kann man sich echt nicht beschweren
und ich könnte wetten, wenn wir jetzt wirklich so Raw Window aufmachen würden, ohne Forms und ohne den ganzen Geschiss, wären wir wahrscheinlich unter 100
Bilder brauchen halt einfach ein bisschen Speicherplatz, unkomprimierte Bilder, das hat ein bisschen was
jetzt mal ausrechnen, 600 x 600 x 4, so, hallo Google, please, so, bytes to MB, ok das ist nicht so wirklich viel
aber Bilder brauchen halt ein bisschen was, vor allem wenn sie größer werden
warte mal, doch habe ich richtig gerechnet, kann sein ich habe was vergessen, also kleine Bilder gehen noch
ich stelle dir mal ein unkomprimiertes Video vor, das ist in der Regel, also rein das Anzeigen ist ziemlich angenehm, weil du nichts decoden musst
also vorausgesetzt, man kann es schnell genug lesen, ist das super, das hat kaum CPU Last unkomprimierte Videos, weil du halt nichts decoden musst
sie sind halt riesengroß, ja, also wenn du mit deinem C++ Zeug dann quasi 60 MB hast, ich habe hier noch ein bisschen Managed Grempel drum herum
dann ist das mit 100 MB oder sowas, was das hier hat, und wie viel hatte das hier jetzt, ja dann ist das doch vollkommen ok, also 118, das ist doch top
kann man nichts sagen, ja, denke ich auch, 120 MB ist wirklich top, und man muss sich mal gucken, wie sau schnell das ist, das ist halt einfach instant
und man muss es halt mal ohne Debugger machen, zack da, das ist nix, wir müssen uns noch ein bisschen um das Handling kümmern, also wir müssen noch resizeen und so einbauen
das müssen wir noch machen, dass wir noch resizeen können das Fenster, das müssen wir noch einbauen, das machen wir aber das nächste Mal
ja Flo, du machst das nächste Mal den Giftplay in Assembler, easy, dann verwende ich den auch, wenn du mir den Assembler machst, auf, go go
ja da kannst du im Prinzip, da muss ich jetzt TheraFox schon recht geben, im Prinzip kannst du ja nicht so viel unterschiedliches speichern eigentlich
du hast halt deine drei Bytes für Farben und hast halt einen Byte für Transparenz, was willst du mehr machen, das einzige wo du variieren kannst ist halt, dass du wieder die RGB Dinge anordnest
BGA, RGB, GAA, was auch immer es da alles für Varianten wahrscheinlich gibt
das heißt bei C-Sharp nochmal der Krams den man mit Attribute meintst du
Juff gibt es auch noch ja, da ist der Colorspace ein bisschen anders und noch ein paar andere Sachen, die ich jetzt, weiß ich jetzt nicht genau
ja Patrick auf gehts, Assembler, go go
also TheraFox ich hab mir grad mal dein C++ Beispiel angeguckt, was ich nicht checke ist, du machst ja ganz unten Sleep 4 Milliseconds, so und dann mal 1000, was für eine Zahl übergibst du denn Sleep 4, was steht denn da drin so als Beispiel
sag mal ein Beispiel als Zahl, steht da da irgendwie sowas drin wie 16,7 oder was oder wie
richtig, das könnte man noch viel schöner darstellen, aber die Sache ist die FFmpeg haut mir ja quasi hier an der Stelle, da müsste man sich schon richtig das Bein ausreißen
weil das FFmpeg die Code gibt dir halt quasi ein BGRA Memory Block zurück
also ein BGRA Memory Block zurück
so leute ich werde jetzt mal meine pizza futtern
er meint wenn du das quasi in milisekunden schreiben würdest oder also sprich wenn du
die sekunden in milisekunden haben willst was ja natürlich mehr wird an der sista hat
verschrieben ok oder auch nicht weil das aussehen ergeben hat ja also wenn es mal
1000 rechnest da hast halt das was du in milisekunden schreiben müsstest dass du
wieder auf sekunden kommst
ich bin echt begleitet wie flüssig das ist ich finde auch wenn man sich das hier
anguckt im vergleich jetzt zu zu der wpf geschichte ich finde auch es ist
flüssig guckt euch das mal an die animation ist viel flüssiger guckt mal wie wie die hände hier wackeln seht ihr moment meins ist meins hat
auch die falsche falschen fps kann das sein meins hat die falschen fps nö hat es nicht meins hat die richtigen fps meins hat die fps die im
feil stehen wpf kriegt nicht richtig hin guck mal wie lahm das ist ich habe zwei durchläufe bis die ein haben aber meins hat die hat meins hat die fps die das feil sagt dass es hat und wpf hat was auch immer das braucht doppelt so lange oder so wahrscheinlich weil es
tp um ist in hinterherkommt keine ahnung das hier hat keine ahnung 5 fps oder so und der hier hat 25 aber ich nehme das was das feil auslässt wir können ja mal gucken können wir können wir wirklich
checken was das zeug hat ne vlc wir machen ff probe ff probe hat fps 12,5 und der pappagei hat 25 allerdings
ah moment nee keine ahnung müsste müsste eigentlich richtig erkennen macht aber anscheinend nicht läuft ein alter plane als web overlay oder lokal das ist lokal das ist immer zwei sachen also das web interface ist ja dafür gedacht dass du es auf dem tablet oder so verwenden kannst das ist ein transparentes wpf fenster und im hinterkommende asp.net core anwendung das web interface kannst du auf dem tablet verwenden klickst du drauf
und dann geht es ja auf das besteht aus dem aus quasi dem web aus der aus der asp.net core und der wpf anwendung
ja ich weiß dass man gift play mit 25 fps abgespielt hat allerdings ich habe es ja nicht gesetzt guck da ich sage hier die code fps und die code fps ist an der meinung dass es 25 sind was aber
anscheinend nicht stimmt wobei ff probe gibt es aus und ich mache es auch mit ffmpeg das ist irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig
doch da ich bin bin demnächst auf 25 der denkt es sind 25 guck da 25 wo schreibe ich denn hier hin stream frame rate
was habe ich noch zu bieten air rate das können wir auch nochmal machen vielleicht sind die unterschiedlich 25 was haben wir sonst noch so zur auswahl
mal gucken was die anderen dinger ausspucken wenn man das jetzt nochmal richtig schreiben würde alles
bitt rate sample rate was kommt da raus null frame frame rate
ich habe eine idee woran das liegt aha daran liegt das ich ich ich lese das falsch aus guckt mal das richtige ist stream
das richtige ist stream das hat total beknackt das richtige ist stream average frame rate und dann das da geteilt durch das da und dann stimmt das nämlich auch
am 1 ist trotzdem noch flüssiger
was funktioniert nun schon alles fast alles resize klappt noch nicht aber gifs abspielen geht transparente gifs abspielen geht eigentlich
funktioniert alles also das schwierige ist geschafft
musst du die fps nicht später auslesen wenn das das feil ist schon geöffnet ich mache das feile im konstruktor auf also sprich ich kann gar nichts vorher
auslesen bevor ich überhaupt drauf zugreifen kann das feil ist auf jeden fall da ich habe es jetzt ja hier richtig ich habe den die zweite komponente nicht
ausgelesen an der stelle hier jetzt stimmt ja mit 12,5 fps leider gibt es keine halben fps es gibt im prinzip nur 12 oder 13
oder 13
ja das ist schön das gefällt mir
das gefällt mir echt gut so leute ich gehe jetzt mal eine pizza futtern wir sehen uns demnächst machts gut bis denn tschüss
gibt es irgendwas zu hausten wen kann ich hausten
keine ahnung irgendwie keiner da der frazier der spielt nicht
da gehe ich jetzt einfach auf
remix
so alles gut
so
SWR 2020